I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everybody. Hi there.
我是珍娜·费舍，我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你制作了这个终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女郎。大家好。大家好。
It's time. It is time. We have arrived at Threat Level Midnight. It is Season 7, Episode 17. It was directed by Tucker Gates, written by BJ Novak, and guess who is here with us today? BJ Novak! Woohoo! All the Tucker Gates fans are like, oh, okay, that's okay, too, but okay.
时候到了。真的是时候了。我们迎来了《午夜威胁级别》。这是第七季第十七集。本片由塔克·盖茨执导，BJ·诺瓦克编剧，大家猜猜今天谁和我们在一起？BJ·诺瓦克！呜呼！所有塔克·盖茨的粉丝大概都会想，哦，好吧，那也行吧，不过好吧。
BJ, we're so excited that you're going to talk about this episode with us. I absolutely loved rewatching it. I watched the extended version on the DVD, which is also amazing. I watched the extended version and then I went back and I watched the client because I was like, I need to know where it all began. I need to see it again. Oh, my God. I forgot so many different twists and turns of Michael Starr.
BJ，你能和我们一起聊聊这一集，我们真的超级兴奋。我太喜欢重温它了。我看了DVD上的加长版，那也太棒了。我看了加长版，然后我又回去看《客户》那一集，因为我在想，我需要知道这一切是从哪里开始的。我需要再看一遍。天哪。我忘了迈克尔·斯科特身上有那么多不同的曲折。
Yes. The great thing that we discovered with the client, I feel, is how many things you learn about someone by watching something they didn't know was revealing something about them. So Michael's screenplay, I forget it, brother, and that, oh, wow, okay, he changed white. All these little things, it's not just what a stupid screenplay, it's you actually get a window into who he was writing it, which is so cute and hard to watch, which is a lot of Michael Scott. Let me just say how happy I am that you brought me on to talk about this.
是的。我觉得我们在《客户》中发现的棒极了的一点是，通过观看那些当事人并不知道会暴露自己隐私的事情，你能了解一个人多少。所以迈克尔的剧本，我忘了兄弟，还有那个，哦，哇，好吧，他把白人改了。所有这些小细节，不仅仅是一部愚蠢的剧本，你实际上得到了一个了解他是谁的窗口，是谁在写它，这太可爱了，也很难看，这也是很大一部分迈克尔·斯科特。让我先说一下，你能带我来聊这个，我有多高兴。
This is my happiest experience, probably, with an episode. It's the one that I, especially last time you had me on about Scott Stott's, it was like, all right, let's get into it. That's the least comfortable one that I worked on. This is the most joyous, like this was really a victory lap for Steve and the whole cast, for me and the writers. It was just like, ugh, like it was really a pure joyous episode. We could have done a two hour version.
这可能是我对某一集的最快乐的经历。这是我特别是在上次你让我上节目聊斯科特·托茨时，就觉得，好吧，我们开始吧。那是我参与过最不舒服的一集。这是最欢乐的，这真的像是史蒂夫和整个演员阵容，对我还有编剧们的一场胜利巡游。就感觉，呃，就像它真的是一个纯粹快乐的一集。我们本来可以做一个两小时的版本。
So I'm just happy to reminisce about it. Angela, weren't you saying that on the commentary Dave Rogers was talking about the joy? Yes. On the DVD commentary, there are you, Craig Robinson, Creed Bratton, Charlie Grandy, and Dave Rogers, and Dave shared how jazzed everyone was after the table read. He said the table read was so electric and everyone was so into it and having such a ball, Steve was so into it and everyone left feeling super pumped after the table read. They couldn't wait to dive in this episode.
所以我很高兴能回忆起它。安吉拉，你刚才不是说戴夫·罗杰斯在评论音轨里谈到了那种快乐吗？是的。在DVD的评论音轨里，有你、克雷格·罗宾逊、克里德·布拉顿、查理·格兰迪和戴夫·罗杰斯，戴夫分享了大家在围读剧本后是多么兴奋。他说围读剧本时气氛太热烈了，每个人都极其投入，玩得非常开心，史蒂夫也极其投入，大家在围读结束后离开时都感到热血沸腾。他们迫不及待地想要投入到这一集中。
Like all departments were so excited. Yeah. And you see that in the episode. Well, BJ, where did the idea for doing threat level midnight as a full episode come from? It came directly from Steve. When we went into the final season, I might be conflating memories, but as I remember it, Greg asked Steve, Greg Daniels asked him, is there anything you want to do before you leave?
就像所有部门都超级兴奋。是的。你在这一集里也能看出来。那么，BJ，将“午夜威胁级别”拍成完整一集的想法是从哪里来的？它直接来自于史蒂夫。当我们进入最后那一季时，我可能记忆有些混淆，但据我所记，格雷格问史蒂夫，格雷格·丹尼尔斯问他，在你离开之前，有什么你想做的事吗？
And he said, let me think about it. And then one day, I remember I was walking from the writer's building to the part of the parking lot where you run into each other, right? Yeah, yeah, right. Between like the writer's office, which is part of Thunderbolt and the other part. And Steve is there like with his suit and untucked shirt, you know, he was like, hey, I realized the episode I want to do. I want to see threat level midnight.
他说，让我想想。然后有一天，我记得我正从编剧大楼走到停车场你们会偶遇的那片区域，对吧？对，对，对。就在类似雷霆号（Thunderbolt）一部分的编剧办公室和另一部分之间。史蒂夫就在那里，穿着西装，衬衫下摆没塞进裤子里，你知道，他就说，嘿，我想通了我想拍的一集。我想看《午夜威胁级别》。
And I was so excited to run back and tell the writers. And it's like, you know, when you get news before anyone else, like I had just received this news. I got the little nugget. I was like, I talked to Steve. Like Steve, here's what Steve wants to do. Threat level midnight and everyone lit into a big grin. It's like, we can grant that wish.
我当时兴奋极了，赶紧跑回去告诉编剧们。这就好比，你知道的，当你比任何人都早得到消息时，就像我刚刚收到了这个消息。我得到了这个小宝藏。我就像，我跟史蒂夫聊过了。史蒂夫，史蒂夫想做这个。午夜威胁级别，每个人脸上都露出了灿烂的笑容。就像，我们可以满足这个愿望。
That is a great wish. And probably because I reported it with such excitement, it seemed like I was the guy to write it. And I was, you know, I got the assignment. I was going to ask you that, how did you get assigned this script? Do you think it was because you're the person who ran into him in the parking lot? I think the fact that I came in with that big grin, that grin was intoxicating to the room.
那真是一个伟大的愿望。可能因为我汇报时带著极大的兴奋，显得我就是那个最适合写它的人。而我确实是，你知道的，我接到了这个任务。我正要问你呢，你是怎么接到这个剧本任务的？你觉得是因为你在停车场偶遇了他吗？我觉得是因为我带着那个大大的笑容走进来的，那个笑容对房间里的人很有感染力。
I was the right messenger of it. But I also think because I had been there, I had been there from the client. Not all the writers were still there is only a few of us that had been there back then. And it was really like a full circle. It was also my swan song, the way it was Steve's as a writer. That's the kind of thing I loved writing. I had been kind of in a rut writing in my opinion. I mean, the viewers don't notice this stuff because they all end up being written collectively
我是传达这个消息的合适人选。但我也觉得是因为我在那儿，我从《客户》那一集起就在那儿了。编剧已经不全在那儿了，只有我们少数人是从那个时候就在的。这真是一个完美的圆满。这也是我的天鹅绝唱，就像史蒂夫作为编剧一样。这就是我喜欢写的那种东西。依我之见，我当时写东西有点陷入泥潭了。我的意思是，观众不会注意到这些，因为它们最终都是集体创作出来的
anyway. But like, I'm like assigned Prince Family paper. I don't remember what it is exactly. Just like, I'm like, what happened to that? That's what she said, like the greatest things, you know, and just like a big, funny, juicy topic. And so to have Threat level midnight, it kind of was like, there's got to be some metaphor there, but like, you know, time travel to me, like back to the early days of like anything
无论如何。但比如，我被指派写《普林斯家族纸业》。我不记得具体是什么了。就像，我就在想，那个怎么了？这就是她说过的话，你知道的，诸如此类最棒的事情，就像一个盛大、有趣、多汁的话题。所以能有《午夜威胁级别》，它有点像——这里面肯定有什么隐喻，但你知道的，对我来说就像时间旅行，回到早期那种任何事情
can happen, you know, these characters are so wild and yet so rich and it was, and it was comedy. It wasn't, we didn't have too much drama to service, although the poignancy of Michael having made this ridiculous movie that he has invested all of this fantasy in the idea that it's great. We all have that thing, you know, the novel that you've, you're going to write someday, the screenplay, you're going to write someday, the role you're going to play someday, you know, and not just us in the business, everybody pretty much has that thing they think they
都可能发生的时期，你知道，这些角色如此疯狂，却又如此丰富，而且它是喜剧。它不是，我们没有太多需要服务的戏剧性，尽管迈克尔创作了这个荒谬的电影，并将他所有的幻想都倾注在它“很棒”这个想法上，这种辛酸感是存在的。我们都有那种东西，你知道的，你总有一天会写的小说，你总有一天会写的剧本，你总有一天会演的角色，你知道的，不仅是我们这个行业的人，几乎每个人都有那种他们认为
might write someday and they'd be very crushed if it were read and declared not good. You know, we cling to that. And so Michael had that. And so the poignancy of something that to us is the silliest thing we've ever seen in the best way. And to him is like, that's his masterpiece. If he doesn't have that, he's not, you know, not a secret genius, not talented. That made it poignant, but there wasn't, it wasn't like, you know, Jim and Karen getting
自己总有一天会写出来，并且如果它被读到并被宣称不好，他们会非常崩溃的东西。你知道，我们紧紧抓住那个不放。所以迈克尔也有那个。因此，对我们来说最愚蠢、以最好的方式来看是滑稽的事情，对她而言却是他的杰作，这种反差带来的辛酸感——如果他没有那个，他就不是，你知道的，不是一个秘密的天才，不是很有才华。这让它变得辛酸，但又不是那种，你知道的，吉姆和凯伦变得
serious, you know, it wasn't any one of those plots. I loved watching it just because it made me miss the early seasons. We're having so much fun rewatching the show. That's what I mean. It was an early season vibe. Yeah. And just even from like the conference room scene in the very beginning where everyone's like laughing at the movie and he gets his feelings hurt and you're dressed as Pam.
严肃起来的剧情，它不是那些情节中的任何一个。我喜欢看它，纯粹是因为它让我想起了前几季。我们重温这部剧时玩得太开心了。这就是我的意思。它有一种前几季的氛围。是的。甚至从一开始的会议室场景开始，每个人都在嘲笑这部电影，然后他伤心了，而你打扮成帕姆的样子。
I mean, you're dressed as like OG Pam with your cardigan and your hair and the whole thing. Yeah. And you just felt that sort of Jim and Pam, I don't know, early days, it made me nostalgic to want to go back and start the, start the rewatch over again. Yeah, that was a really smart thing this late in the run of the show to give us like this, this travel back in time to Pam sitting next to Roy on the floor and you're like, oh my gosh, look how far their lives have come.
我的意思是，你穿着类似元祖帕姆的衣服，穿着开衫，梳着发型，整个造型都是。是的。你就能感受到那种吉姆和帕姆的，我不知道，早期的感觉，这让我产生了一种怀旧之情，想要回去把重温之旅重新开始。是的，在剧集进行到这个后期，能安排这样一次时光倒流，让帕姆坐在罗伊旁边的地板上，你会觉得，哦天哪，看看他们的生活已经走了多远，这真的是一个非常聪明的安排。
I know. And then, and then to cut back to Jim and Pam when like Jim is golden face and he, Pam looks at him like, oh my God, I can't believe you did that. Like you, you see so much. Right. You wouldn't have done that. And like the people doing the scarn is so interesting because it's like who he did and didn't get.
我知道。然后，然后镜头切回吉姆和帕姆，当吉姆扮演黄金脸，而帕姆看着他时，就像，哦天哪，我不敢相信你做到了。就像你，你能看到很多。没错。你以前不会这么做的。而且扮演斯科恩舞的人也很有趣，因为这就像他争取到了谁和没争取到谁一样。
Like, I think Rashida is in it, right? Yeah. That's the last person that would have done this. And yet, you know what? At that moment, he was her boss and it wasn't that stupid a thing to do, I guess, didn't take up too much time. So here we go. We learned the dance.
比如，我记得拉什达在里面，对吧？是的。那是最后一个会做这种事的人。然而，你知道吗？在那一刻，他是她的老板，而且这也不是什么太蠢的事，我想，也没有占用太多时间。所以，我们开始吧。我们学会了这支舞。
You know, it's funny. It's cute that, that some people would have done it. Angela, your character does the scarn. Oh, yes, I do the scarn. Yes. You doing the scarn is even wilder, but like, it's your boss. What's really funny is I went back and read the shooting draft and it said that when you cut to the Bachelorette group in the corner, it's Meredith Phyllis Karen and Angela.
你知道，这很有趣。有些人会愿意做这件事，这很可爱。安吉拉，你的角色跳了斯科恩舞。哦，是的，我跳了斯科恩舞。是的。你跳斯科恩舞就更疯狂了，但毕竟，他是你的老板。真正有趣的是，我回去读了拍摄剧本，上面说当镜头切换到角落里的一群单身派对女孩时，那是梅雷迪思、菲利斯、凯伦和安吉拉。
Angela has brought her work and is doing work. She has papers, like accounting papers, so she's sort of begrudgingly there. And then we each have a line when the bartender, you know, when Andy's like, the, the Bachelorette party sent you over a cocktail. I actually printed out what we said over in the Bachelorette corner. So both Meredith and Phyllis go, hey, and then Meredith goes, who ordered the man burger? Well done. And Phyllis says, hey, hot stuff.
安吉拉把工作带到了派对上，正在工作。她拿着文件，比如会计文件，所以她算是心不甘情愿地呆在那里。然后当酒保过来时——你知道的，当安迪说，单身派对送了你一杯鸡尾酒时，我们每个人都有一句台词。我实际上把我们在单身派对角落里说的话打印出来了。所以梅雷迪思和菲利斯都说，嘿，然后梅雷迪思说，谁点的人肉汉堡？做得好。菲利斯说，嘿，性感宝贝。
One last fling. And then Angela says, come and ride the choo choo. And then in parentheses, it says, pained, the sex choo choo. That sounds right. And then it cuts to Karen's line. And that's what made it in. But we filmed that. I remember filming the sex choo choo.
最后疯狂一次。然后安吉拉说，来骑呜呜车吧。接着在括号里写着，痛苦地，性爱呜呜车。听起来没错。然后镜头切到凯伦的台词。这就是最终播出的内容。但我们确实拍了。我记得拍摄性爱呜呜车的那场戏。
It's in the extended DVD version, that whole Bachelorette scene in that version. And Andy is like such a ham, of course, as the bartender, which he would be. So yeah, that was very fun doing all that math. But I think a lot of it, which is sweet and part of the spirit of the office too, is that people just do things when someone is excited about it. And I think it's why Michael Scott was a good salesman. And it's why the people the barred at the Skarn. A guy comes in with wild eyes and little boy energy and tells you everything he's going
在DVD加长版里，那一整个单身派对的场景都在那个版本里。安迪就像个戏精一样，当然了，作为酒保他本该如此。所以，是的，做所有这些数学运算非常有趣。但我认为很大一部分，这很甜蜜，也是办公室精神的一部分，那就是当有人对某事感到兴奋时，人们就会去做。我想这也是为什么迈克尔·斯科特是个好销售员的原因。这也是为什么大家会在酒吧里跳斯科恩舞。一个眼神狂野、带着小男孩般冲劲的家伙走进来，告诉你他打算做的一切。
to do. And here's what you're going to do. And here's how great it's going to be. And you're just like, OK, sure. It's harder to cross your arms and be like, no, thank you. Some people do that, but people just do things. And that's what you sent me last night, the David Wallace talking head that got cut where he says, I should have done it.
而这就是你要做的。这就是它会有多棒。然后你就会觉得，好吧，当然。交叉双臂说“不，谢谢你”要难得多。有些人会那样做，但人们就是会去做。这就是你昨晚发给我的那段被剪掉的大卫·华莱士的面对镜头独白，他在里面说，我本该加入的。
You know, like, yeah, I think at the end of the day, you look back on things and you the people who do say I'm not doing that, they regret it like life is short. No one's paying attention to what you do. Like even if you David Wallace shouldn't be in this movie, like whatever, you'll all not work here someday. Just say yes. Yeah. That energy, that little boy wild-eyed energy where someone gets an idea and then you end
你知道，就像，是的，我觉得归根结底，你回首往事时，那些说“我才不干”的人，他们会后悔的——人生苦短。没有人真正在意你在做什么。就像即使大卫·华莱士不应该出现在这部电影里，管他的呢，你们总有一天都不会在这里工作了。只要说“好”就行了。是的。那种能量，那种小男孩般狂野的眼神，当某人有了个点子，然后你最终做了一件你没想过你会做的事，这简直是我和约翰·卡拉辛斯基经历过的所有情况的写照。
up doing something that you didn't think you were going to do is literally every situation I've ever been in with John Krasinski. Yeah. Right? Doesn't John Krasinski, he can be like, Jenna, get Lee. We're going to Vegas this weekend. I'm like, we are. We're going to Vegas.
是的。对吧？难道约翰·卡拉辛斯基不会说，珍娜，把李叫上。我们这个周末要去拉斯维加斯。我就像，我们要去吗？我们要去拉斯维加斯。他说，我们要去了。我有票。我说，你有一张写着我名字的票。不，不，不。我有票。你搞到票。我们走。等等，我甚至都没听说过这次旅行。
He's like, we're doing it. I have tickets. I'm like, you have a ticket in my name. No, no, no. I have tickets. You get tickets. We're going. Wait, I didn't even heard about this trip.
这次旅行真的发生了吗？我想是的。还是说？这是一次真正的旅行。是的。是的。好吧。第一，我们站在邓德米夫林的停车场上。
Did this trip happen? I guess we are. Or is this? This was a real trip. Yes. Yes. Okay. One, we're standing out in the parking lot of Dunder Mifflin.
我们正在拍某场戏，约翰在打电话，他走回来，就说，你这个周末在干嘛？我说，我不知道。我想我和李可能会，他说，你要去拉斯维加斯。我们全都要去拉斯维加斯。我说，我们要去吗？我们要去拉斯维加斯。他说，对。
We're doing some scene, John's on the phone, he comes back, he's like, what are you doing this weekend? I'm like, I don't know. I think Lee and I might, he goes, you're going to Vegas. We're all going to Vegas. I'm like, we are. We're going to Vegas. He's like, yeah.
对。你能赶上6点30的航班吗？然后我就，我甚至都——然后我打电话给李说，我想我们要去拉斯维加斯了。这太棒了。这就是他为什么这么成功的原因。这也是为什么迈克尔·斯科特用他自己的方式取得了成功。我们所有人都应该更像那样，因为想想看另一边的感受。我的意思是，你就是那样的人。
Yeah. Can you make a 630 flight? And I'm like, I don't even, and then I call Lee and I'm like, I think we're going to Vegas. It's the best. It's why he's so successful. It's why Michael Scott was successful in his way. It's all of us should be more like that because think of how it feels on the other side. I mean, you were that person.
有人带着那种狂野的眼神走到你面前说，你要去拉斯维加斯。你就说，我们要去了。我有三件事需要处理。我能以多快的速度，你知道的，我必须撤销我这个周末原本打算做的三件事。是的。最糟糕的是，最糟糕的是当你和别人做计划时，他们说，我不知道，你想去哪儿？你知道，哦不，那样的话你甚至永远都不会去到，去到奇利餐厅（Chili's）。你知道，我知道，我知道。
Someone comes up to you with that wildlife site and said, you're going to Vegas. You're like, we are three things I need to take care of. How quickly can I, you know, I have to undo three things that I was going to do this weekend. Yeah. And the worst, the worst is when you're making plans with someone and they're like, I don't know, where do you want to go? You know, oh no, then you're never even going to, to Chili's that way. You know, I know, I know.
我曾在日记里写过，不要，不要找一个“也许先生”。我找到了那个。哇。是的。对我说不要什么“也许先生”。这是一个很好的，这是一个很好的浪漫喜剧台词。也许先生。好吧，你知道那个片名，虽然是一部烂片，但那个场面，那个场景就像诺拉
I once wrote in my journal, don't, don't find a Mr. Maybe. I found that. Wow. Yeah. Don't know Mr. Maybe's for me. This is a good, that's a good rom-com bit of dialogue. Mr. Maybe. Well, the title, you know, it's a lame movie, but that scene, that scene and like a Nora
埃夫隆级别的浪漫喜剧里的场景，人们都会引用。就像，你知道安吉拉说“我才不要什么也许先生”的那场戏。这就是他。他就是一个“也许先生”。是的。我能扯远一点吗，顺便说一句，迈克尔在《午夜威胁级别》里也试图这么做，所以这把它们联系起来了，但现在人们不再为流行语买账了。哦，是的。
Efron level rom-com is the scene people quote. It's like, you know, that scene where Angela goes, I don't want to Mr. Maybe. That's how that's who he is. He's a Mr. Maybe. Yeah. Can I just go on a tangent like also, and Michael tried to do this in threat level midnight, so it ties it in, but people don't go for the catchphrase is enough anymore. Oh yeah.
是的，麦克·迈尔斯才是王者，比如麦克·迈尔斯在《韦恩的世界》和《王牌大贱谍》里。所以这绝非偶然。有大约五个流行语在30年后依然闻名遐迩。你知道的，没门。是的。宝贝。哦，别这样。
Yeah, Mike Myers was the king, like Mike Myers in Wayne's World and Austin Power. So it wasn't a fluke. There are like five catchphrases that are famous 30 years later. You know, not. Yeah. Yeah. Baby. Oh, be hate.
诸如此类的流行语有那么多。我最近看了《甜心先生》，里面大约还有五个流行语。你一开口我就沦陷了。哦，是的。你一开口我就沦陷了。你完整了我。让我看到钱。让我看到钱。
Like, there's so many things that are catchphrases. And I watched Jerry Maguire recently, there are like five catchphrases still. You had me at hello. Oh yeah. You had me at hello. You complete me. Show me the money. Show me the money.
这太疯狂了。如果那样的人能做到，我们应该更多地去做，你知道的，但迈克尔知道这一点。迈克尔知道。好吧，我们有这个。这就是她说过的话。是的。我们有这个。
Like this is crazy. And if people like that can do it, like we should be doing it more, you know, but like Michael knew that. Michael knew that. Well, we had that. That's what she said. Yeah. We had that.
是的。你在评论音轨里说过，你们在编剧室里为了想出迈克尔的流行语玩得超级开心。所以你知道，五号清理现场是我们在这里的目的，但显然还有更多。是的。还有更多，五号清理现场。而且我觉得这是最好的，因为——它没有双重含义。
Yeah. You said on the commentary that you guys had so much fun in the writer's room just pitching Michael's catchphrase. So you know, clean up on all five is what we're here, but you apparently there's like so many more. Yes. There are so many more and clean up on all five. And I think it was the best because like it didn't have a double meaning.
是的，没错。如果它发生在商店里，它甚至连一个含义都没有，它就没有任何含义。所以我记得我们有一次在讨论，BJ，关于是否应该将《午夜威胁级别》那一集包含办公室里的场景，还是应该把它做成独立的一集，当时有很多讨论。对吧？你谈谈那个。
Yeah, exactly. It didn't even have one meaning if it happened in a store, it would have a meaning and like there's just no meaning. So I remember we were talking once, BJ, about how there was a lot of discussion about whether or not the threat level midnight episode should include like scenes in the office or if it should be standalone. Right. You talk about that.
是的。有几个重大决定要做，而我输了那场争论。不过我太庆幸我输了。当时有两种选择，一种是真正成为喜剧书呆子纯粹主义者，直接推出《午夜威胁级别》。把这部电影作为独立的一集，粉丝们会懂的。那会非常特别。而且这种观点有它的道理。现在依然有。
Yeah. There were a couple of big decisions to make and I lost that argument. I'm so glad I did. The two ways to go were be really like comedy nerd purist and just drop threat level midnight. The movie as an episode, fans will figure it out. It will be so special. And there's there's an argument for that. There still is.
它非常特别、引人注目，然而这就好像《废柴联盟》会做的那样——其实仔细想想，这种花招并不那么罕见，你知道的，而且我们不是那种靠花招博眼球的剧。我们有自己的结构，而这会把注意力吸引到结构上。如果你打破了结构，你知道的，那个隐形的纪录片结构。所以我非常庆幸，而且删掉那些关于《午夜威胁级别》的场景本可以让电影呈现更多内容，我其实希望我们能看到更多。但你确实看到了。
It's so special and eye catching and yet it's like what community would have done like it's gimmicks are not that rare actually when you think about it, you know, and it we're not like a gimmick show. We have a structure and it calls attention to the structure. If you break the structure, you know, the invisible documentary structure. So I am very glad even and also cutting those scenes about threat level midnight would have allowed more of the movie, which I wish we could have seen. But you do see that.
我觉得这也是类似DVD花絮或者在YouTube上能看到的内容。我觉得整部电影，整部电影在DVD和YouTube上都有。我很高兴我输了那场争论，因为——因为你当时在争论要把它作为一个独立的剧集推出。是的，我希望它能很酷，带点喜剧色彩，向其他喜剧书呆子炫耀我们做了一件一开始有点难以理解的事情。但是你知道的，我很高兴我输了。你懂的。
I think that's also like a DVD extra like or it's on YouTube. I think the whole movie, the whole movie is both on the DVD and on YouTube. I'm so glad I lost that argument because it is so much because you were arguing to drop it as its own episode. Yeah, I want it to be cool and like comedy, you know, show off to the other comedy nerds that we did something that was a little hard to get it first. But you know, and I'm glad I lost that. You get it.
是的。我很高兴我输了那场争论，因为第一，那会分散观众对投入剧集现实感的注意力。第二，它所蕴含的情感意义非常重要。你知道的，就像我刚才说的，这太愚蠢了，而它的愚蠢正在击碎迈克尔·斯科特的头脑，因为他无法接受它并不好这个事实。如果他接受了这一点，就会击碎他的心。而霍莉的出现，是将他从那个幻想中幼稚版的自己（也就是“如果我想的话，我可以成为西尔维斯特·史泰龙”，你知道的）
Yeah. I'm glad I lost that argument because, A, that is a distracting thing from investing in the reality of the show. And also the emotional meaning of it is very important. And you know, like I was saying that this is so silly and how silly it is, is breaking Michael Scott's brain because he can't wrap his mind around it, not being good. And it's breaking his heart if he accepts that. And Holly is there to take him from the fantasy kid version of him, which is like, I can be
拉回到成年版的自己——也就是，你是一个好人，你曾经和你的朋友们拍过一部愚蠢的电影。哦，这要美好得多，尽管很难接受，但这赋予了它某种意义。嗯，而且迈克尔现在可以开始放下他的幻想生活了，因为他现在全身心投入到真实生活中了。对他来说，这是一件成长极大的事。我很喜欢回到——我猜是附楼的那个场景，当时迈克尔开始意识到
Sylvester Stallone if I want, you know, to the adult version, which is, you are a wonderful guy who made a silly movie at one point with his friends. And like, oh, that's so much more beautiful, but it's hard to accept, but that gives it, that gives it some meaning. Well, and Michael can start letting go of his fantasy life before now because he's invested in his real life now. It's a huge growing up thing for him. I love that scene back in, I guess, the Annex when Michael is coming to the realization
她并没有把这视为什么杰作。而她说出了那句台词：“我觉得这是你和朋友们一起做的一件非常有趣的事。”是的。我觉得，我觉得你应该珍惜这一点。这直接来自于我年轻时经历的一个艰难时刻，当时我在大学里花了一整年时间拍了一部电影，我以为会——你知道的，哦，我一直想成为一名电影制作人，你知道的，这就是——顺便说一句，它叫《字母汤》。
that she doesn't see it as the masterpiece that he does. And she has that line where she says, I think it's a really fun thing you did with your friends. Yeah. I think, I think you should value that. That directly comes from a hard moment in my youth when I had spent all year making a movie in college that I thought would be, you know, oh, I had always wanted to be filmmaker and, you know, this is, this is it was called alphabet soup, by the way.
我拍了这部电影，花了一整年时间。由我的室友切斯、切斯的妈妈和其他人在年底出演。她说，重要的是你和朋友们一起做了一件有趣的事，而我当时暴跳如雷。我太沮丧了，因为在她看来，这竟然只是那么一回事，实在是太显而易见了。这只是一种，带有感伤色彩的，“哦，我记得我们拍过那部电影”的记忆。而我就想，不，我绝不会那样做，我本来可以在周末和朋友们胡闹的。
And I made this movie and I spent all year on it. And it starred my roommate, chess, and chess's mom and other side at the end of the year. And she said, the important thing is that you got to make something fun with your friends and I was enraged. I was so upset that it was so obvious to her that that's all it was. It was, you know, a sentimental, like, oh, I remember we made that movie. And I was like, no, I would never have done, I could have goofed around with my friends on the weekend.
就像，这是我的电影。很多时候——有趣的是，甚至连这个，我们的，你知道的，在这里《办公室女郎》的重聚，也是生活中那种紧张关系的一个例子。你知道的，归根结底，珍娜和安吉拉，你们，办公室是你们和朋友们一起做的事情吗？还是说，老实说，很明显它远不止于此，你们因此赚了钱、开创了职业生涯，它对很多人来说意义重大。如果我必须选一个，另一方面，这毕竟是你们的生活。
Like, this was my film. And so many times, and it's funny, I mean, even this, our, you know, reunion here on Office Ladies is, is an example of that tension in life, too. You know, at the end of the day, Jenna and Angela, like, you, is the office something you did with your friends? Or is it something, honestly, like, obviously, it's so much more, you made money and career on it and it's meant a lot to a lot of people. If I had to pick one, I mean, on the other hand, that's your life at the end of the day.
你知道的，所以如果有人说——而且我想你们对《办公室》可能很有安全感，如果不是的话你们就是精神失常了，因为你签约的时候永远无法预知它会进展得这么顺利。但如果有人对你们说，你知道的，难道不是很棒吗，最重要的是你和朋友们一起完成了这个？我想你们会百分之百地说“是的”，因为我们对此很有安全感。但对像我这样从一出生就野心勃勃、不懂得珍惜生活、爱情和人际关系的人来说，这是一个比较缓慢的课题
You know, so if, if someone said, and I think you're probably so secure about the office and if not your psychotic, because you never get, it never breaks that well, you know, when you sign up for something. But if someone said to you, you know, isn't that great, isn't the most important thing that you got to make that with your friends? I think you'd say 100% because we're secure about that. But I think for me, as someone who was so ambitious from the second I was born and did not value life and love and connections and stuff, that has been a slower lesson for me
也是一个更难的课题。所以我真的把这一点写进了霍莉的场景里，因为我曾经就是迈克尔·斯科特那样的人。但平心而论，当你把心血倾注在一件事上时，却用“真棒啊，你和朋友一起做过这个”作为赞美的开场白——我们可以说，难道不是很棒吗，归根结底，《办公室》是我们和朋友一起做的事，因为在这之前还有成百万件别的事。不，你是对的。
and a harder one. And so I really, I put that into the, the Holly scene because I had, I had been Michael Scott, you know, about that. But to be fair, when you have put your heart into something to lead with the compliment, isn't it great that you made something with your friend, like we, we can say like, isn't it great at the end of the day, the office is something we made with our friends because there's like a million other things that come before that, you know. No, you're right.
它是。它是。不，你是对的。为了捍卫我自己免受冒犯，对别人的工作说这样的话确实是非常轻蔑的。我同意你的看法。是的。所以你们在评论音轨里谈论的事情之一，BJ， literalmente你和查理
It is. It is. No, you're right. In my defense for being offended, it is a very dismissive thing to say about someone's work. I agree with you. Yeah. So one of the things you guys talked about on the commentary, BJ, literally you and Charlie
当这个场景出现时简直在咯咯笑。就像咯咯笑、大笑一样，那段关于《蚁哥正传》对阵《虫虫危机》的独白。你们两个，我猜参与了那段创作，你们真的度过了一段美好的时光，并且非常喜欢那段独白。那是我有史以来最喜欢的迈克尔·斯科特面对镜头独白。哦，天哪，我们应该听听。我们有。我是伍迪·艾伦的超级粉丝，虽然我只看过《蚁哥正传》，但我告诉你一件事。
were giggling when the scene came up. Like giggling, laughing was the monologue about ants versus a bug's life. The two of you, I guess, worked on that and you really had a great time and loved that monologue. That is my favorite Michael Scott talking head of all time. Oh, you guys, we should hear it. We have it. I am a huge Woody Allen fan, although I've only seen ants, but I'll tell you something.
我对那个男人最尊敬的是，当他经历所有那些出现在媒体上的风波时——关于《蚁哥正传》只是一部抄袭《虫虫危机》的作品——他依然忠于他的电影，或者至少是我看过的电影，也就是《蚁哥正传》。问题是，我觉得《虫虫危机》更好，比《蚁哥正传》好得多。重点是，不要听信你的批评者，要听从你的粉丝。BJ，看你回应那个，真是太欢乐了。我记得当你导演一集或监督剧本时，通常你都会蹲在摄像机下方跟演员待在一起，对吧？
What I respect about that man is that when he was going through all of that stuff that came out in the press about how ants was just a ripoff of a bug's life. He stayed true to his films, or at least the film that I saw, which again was ants. Thing is, I thought bug's life was better, much better than ants. Point is, don't listen to your critics, listen to your fans. BJ, watching you answer to that, it's such joy. I remember when you direct an episode or you supervise your writing, generally you crouched below the camera with the actor, right?
你写好了所有的笔记和小点子，所以我会在一旁，如果你们俩谁笑了，另一个也会笑，对吧？我知道这是有史以来最棒的一次一条过，很多次拍摄中，最后我笑了，然后史蒂夫笑了，我就像，谁也别笑，谁也别毁了这镜头，因为这是一条过，我们刚刚做到了，我想你随后就会笑出来。但这段，真的是我绝对的最爱。首先，他的表演令人震惊，因为在这段话背后，他有着极大的痛苦和愤怒，那是真正的情感、真正的情感，而不是一种滑稽模仿的情感，那是真正的情感
You have all written down and little ideas, so I'm there off, and if one of you laughs, the other laughs, right? I know this is the greatest take of all time, and a lot of the takes, what I laugh at the end and then Steve laughs, and I'm like, nobody laugh, nobody ruin this because it's one take and we just got it, and I think you'd laugh right afterwards. But this, it's just my absolute favorite. First of all, his performance is astounding in that he has so much anguish and fury behind true, true emotion, true emotion, not a parody emotion, true emotion behind this thing that
在他所知道的、如此疯狂地离题万里的事情背后。他是个伍迪·艾伦的超级粉丝，好吧，这对于迈克尔·斯科特来说是个惊喜，虽然他只看过《蚁哥正传》，那只是一部由伍迪·艾伦担任配音的小型动画电影，是伍迪·艾伦职业生涯中非常诡异的一次客串，他既没有编写、没有导演，甚至都没有在镜头前出现。是的，这不是一部伍迪·艾伦电影。但这就是他了解伍迪·艾伦的途径，通过《蚁哥正传》。
he also knows is so insanely off topic, so many levels. He's a huge Woody Allen fan, okay, that's a surprise for Michael Scott, although he's only seen ants, which is a minor animated movie that Woody Allen is only a voice in, a very weird one-off in Woody Allen's career, he didn't write or direct it or even appear on camera. Yeah, it's not a Woody Allen film. But that's how he knows Woody Allen is from ants. Right, and he knows that Woody Allen went through a lot of controversy in the press.
没错，而且他知道伍迪·艾伦在媒体上经历了很多争议。他只知道其中最最极端的、微不足道的争议——即《蚁哥正传》抄袭了《虫虫危机》，而不是所有那些关于伍迪·艾伦的真正显而易见的丑闻。而且他还觉得，等等，他觉得哪一部比另一部更好？无论哪一部。
He only knows about the most extremely minor controversy that ants was a rip off of a bug's life, not all the stuff that is the real obvious scandal about Woody Allen. And he also, he thinks, wait, which one does he think is better than the other, whichever one? A bug's life. A bug's life is better. He thinks a bug's life is better than ants, even though he's a huge fan, it's just, and all of this is to say that you don't listen to your critics, which he really means.
《虫虫危机》。《虫虫危机》更好。他觉得《虫虫危机》比《蚁哥正传》更好，尽管他是前者的超级粉丝，这真是……所有这一切都是为了说明，不要听信你的批评者，他是认真的。顺便说一句，我有时会想起这句台词，有时你不是为了取悦你的批评者而创作，你是为了你的粉丝而创作，这是真的，而且我想，我之所以经常想到这一点，可能是在社交媒体时代，你做的任何事都有批评者，你做的每一件事。你发一张自己和家人的照片，都会有批评者，他们可能也有道理。
And by the way, I think of this line, sometimes you don't make up for your critics, you make up for your fans, and that's true, and I think that's actually, probably the reason I think of this a lot is in the social media age, everything you do has critics, everything you do. You post a photo of yourself with your family, it has critics, that probably have a point. They probably have a point, because you can criticize anything. And these days, there's someone said about a comedian that I know, oh, do you think he'll have an audience, whatever.
他们可能确实有道理，因为你可以批评任何事。而且现在，有人评价一个我认识的喜剧演员时说，哦，你觉得他会有观众吗，诸如此类。我的朋友说，他会像所有人一样，不是人人都喜欢。而我就想，对啊，没有人能做到人人都喜欢。你不可能为所有人创作任何东西。你必须为那些懂你的人、为你的粉丝创作。所以我其实经常想起迈克尔·斯科特的这句台词，但它能以这种方式出现真是太疯狂了。
My friend said, he'll be the way everyone is, not for everyone. And I'm like, right, nobody's for everyone. You can't make anything for everyone. You have to make it for the people that get it for your fans. So I actually think of that Michael Scott line a lot, but it's crazy that that's how it got there. I feel like I just took the whole episode, breaking that one thing down, but you could see how much I love that.
我觉得我为了剖析那一件事，把整集都讲完了，但你能看出我有多喜欢它。我的意思是，我愿意听你讲你的任何创作过程，BJ，以及是什么激励了你。我的意思是，我和珍娜一直在谈论这个。哦，好吧，谢谢。不过是的，我想你在播放那个剪辑时在一旁发出的咯咯笑声，可能已经说明了一切。BJ，我们有一个粉丝提问。这是来自宾夕法尼亚州锡尔弗代尔的约翰·C.提出的，他想知道，还有没有其他以前的演员或客串明星，你是想带回这一集，但由于档期冲突而无法邀请到的？你们带回了好多人。
I mean, I could listen to you talk about any of your process, BJ, and what inspires you. I mean, Jenna and I talk about that all the time. Oh, well, thanks. But yes, I think the off-camera giggling that you watched while you were playing that clip is probably says it all about me. BJ, we have a fan question. This is from John C. in Silverdale, Pennsylvania, who would like to know, were there any other previous cast members or guest stars that you wanted to bring in for this episode, but
是的。我想艾米·亚当斯无法参演。是的。兰迪说你们曾试图请回艾米·亚当斯，当时她正在拍一部电影，她感到非常遗憾。她甚至还寄来了一封信。
were unable to get due to scheduling conflicts? You brought back so many people. Yes. I think Amy Adams couldn't do it. Yes. Randy said that you guys tried to get Amy Adams back and she was doing a film and she was really bummed out. She even sent like a letter.
她说，非常感谢你们能想到我，对于无法参演她感到非常遗憾。这真的很有风度。我不记得这件事了，但这恰恰说明了——我们曾想，好吧，艾米，她当时正在拍那么大的电影，而且她只客串过几集。她大概不想回来客串一个闪回和《午夜威胁级别》了吧，但她想的。你知道的，她虽然没能参演，但她是想来的。
She said, thank you so much for thinking of me and that she was so bummed that she couldn't be in it. That was really classy. And I didn't remember that, but it just goes to show like, we thought like, well, Amy, she was doing such enormous movies and she had been like on a few episodes. She doesn't want to come back to do a guest like flashback and threat lowman night, but she did. You know, she didn't do it, but she wanted to.
仅此一点就足以说明她和这部剧的优秀。那么，BJ，你还记得她原本要扮演什么角色吗？我不记得了。好吧，我找到了你以前的一个采访，你说她本来要扮演一个和迈克尔·斯卡恩同床共枕的花痴，德怀特会叫醒他并告诉他总统的任务。在那个场景中，迈克尔要告诉她，他对他们空洞的房事很不满意，因为没有人能像他的妻子那样优秀。
That alone says a lot about her and about the show. So BJ, do you remember what role she was going to play? I don't. Well, I found an old interview with you and you said that she was going to play a flusie who was in bed with Michael Skarn that Dwight would wake him up and tell him about the mission from the president. And in the scene, Michael was going to tell her that he was unsatisfied with their empty love making because no one has ever been as good as his wife.
然后会有一个凯蒂的面对镜头独白，她在里面尴尬地讲述自己是如何参演的，因为她过去对表演有点兴趣。然后你会稍微交代一下她现在在做什么。我喜欢“花痴”这个词只有——我当时一定深深地代入了迈克尔·斯科特，因为我无法想象自己会说，“哦，对，她要演一个花痴。”我其实不太确定“花痴”到底是什么意思，但我知道它就像老电影里的那种廉价尤物。
And then there was going to be a talking head with Katie where she says with embarrassment how she did the role because she had some interest in acting back in the day. And then you were going to kind of catch up with what she's up to now. I love that the word flusie would only have been. I must have really been channeling Michael Scott because I can't imagine saying, oh yeah, she'd play a flusie. I'm not totally sure what a flusie is, but I know it's like a dime a dozen dame from an old type of movie.
这真的——显然太有趣了，我们本可以一直聊下去。看到仓库里的所有小伙子们都跳了斯科恩舞，真的很有趣。而且你们还把戴夫·凯克纳请回来了。天哪，感觉所有人都到齐了。是的，马洛拉。我其实很喜欢那个。我真的很喜欢那首歌。而且我也非常喜欢，我觉得这一集的片尾字幕里有威尔·史密斯版本的
That was just, it's clearly so much fun we could have gone on forever. It was really fun to see all the warehouse guys doing the Skarn. And you got Dave Kekner back. My gosh, everybody felt like everyone was there. Yeah, Malora. I actually love that. I love that song. And I also really love, I think the end credits of the episode has like the Will Smith version
斯科恩舞，就好像——哦，那是完全不同的一首歌。甚至都不是那首歌。哦，甚至都不是那首歌。那是《午夜威胁级别》安迪·伯纳德之歌，由埃德·赫尔姆斯以威尔·史密斯风格的说唱演唱。没错。那是迈克尔的愿景，也就是威尔·史密斯。太棒了。
of the Skarn where like, oh, it's a totally different song. It's not even the song. Oh, it's not even the song. It is the threat level midnight Andy Bernard song, sung by Ed Helms in a Will Smith style rap. Right. And that was Michael's vision that it was Will Smith. It was so good.
我不知道，我想那是查理写的。太搞笑了。让所有的女士都感觉良好，从麦当娜到马德琳·奥尔布赖特。而且我很佩服迈克尔·斯科特会选择如此坚强的女性作为他的梦中情人。这某种程度上是真的，对吧？我知道。我真的觉得——那是一个极好的选择。迈克尔某种程度上是个本能的女权主义者。
I didn't, I think Charlie wrote that. It's so funny. Makes all the ladies feel all right from Madonna to Madeleine Albright. And I did admire that Michael Scott would pick such strong women as his dream women. It's sort of true, right? I know. I really thought like that was a great choice. Michael is sort of like an instinctive feminist.
他很佩服。他喜欢简，你知道的，他喜欢坚强的女性。他觉得她们很性感。我觉得这是迈克尔很酷的一点。而且是的，对他来说，他首选的梦中情人会是麦当娜和马德琳·奥尔布赖特，早在他在2003年左右写下这东西的时候。这很有趣。好吧，我们有。
He does admire. He'd like Jan, you know, he, he likes a strong woman. He thinks they're sexy. And I think that is cool about Michael. And yes, that to him, his go to dream women would be Madonna and Madeleine Albright back whenever he wrote this thing in 2003 or whatever. It's funny. Well, we have it.
就是这个。哦，是的。《午夜威胁级别》让所有的女士都感觉良好，从麦当娜到马德琳·奥尔布赖特。《午夜威胁级别》。这是一个威胁。一个级别，一个级别，级别的威胁。这是我见过最棒的混蛋，还没有。午夜什么威胁，午夜谁威胁，迈克尔·斯卡恩，午夜为什么威胁，种族隔离必须与它抗争，自由曼德拉，和平，我出去了
Here it is. Oh, yeah. Threat level midnight makes all the ladies feel all right from Madonna to Madeleine Albright. Threat level midnight. It's a threat. A level, a level, level threat. These the greatest huckets I've ever seen yet threat level what midnight threat level who Michael scorn threat level why apartheid got to fight it free Mandela piece I'm out
与种族隔离作斗争——这可能是他的本意，但这就是他写那句歌词时的时事梗，太聪明了。所以上周我们采访了比莉·艾利什，我们谈到了她是如何采样《午夜威胁级别》的。
fighting apartheid, which he probably meant, but it was like the cause of the moment when he, the song he was writing that lyric just so smart. So last week we talked to Billie Eilish and we talked about how she sampled threats. Threat level midnight for her song, my strange addiction, BJ. What was it like when you got the call that you had to give permission because your voice is in it. I knew who Billie Eilish was. I was, I didn't really know her music then.
为她的歌曲《我的奇怪瘾好》，BJ。当你接到电话说你需要授权，因为你的声音在里面时，是什么感觉？我知道比莉·艾利什是谁。我当时其实不太了解她的音乐。现在我是她的粉丝了，现在我和她的哥哥芬尼斯（Phineas）是朋友，他制作了很多那种音乐。他为我的电影《复仇》创作了配乐。但当时我不知道，我只知道她是个挺酷的歌手。所以我当时想，哦，酷。而且你知道，从那以后她变得这么火，我也知道她是谁。但对我来说，有趣的部分是，
Now I'm a fan and now I am friends with her brother Phineas who does a lot of that stuff. He composed the score to my movie vengeance. But at the time I didn't, I just knew she was like some cool singer. So I was like, Oh, cool. And you know, since then she became so big and I knew who she was. But to me, the fun part is, um, that song will come on and I will just say to someone, Oh, I'm actually on this song as though I'm like, as though I'm a rapper or something. Yeah.
那首歌放出来时，我会对别人说，“哦，其实这首歌里有我的声音”，就好像我是个说唱歌手或者别的什么。是的。其实这首歌里有我的声音。什么叫这首歌里有你的声音？不，不，我的声音就像——什么？然后就像，很显然它听起来没有那么酷，但它依然——真的。还是很酷的。是的。就像我在这首单曲里。这里有《办公室》的传奇，但除此之外，还有来自《办公室》的《午夜威胁级别》的传奇。
I'm actually on the song. What do you mean you're on this song? No, no, my voice is like, what? And then like, obviously it's not as cool as it sounds, but it's still like, it's true. It's still pretty cool. Yeah. Like I'm on this track. There's the legacy of the office, but then there's also the legacy that is threat level
有人发给我，呃，达阵庆祝。有人在达阵区把斯科恩舞当成舞蹈跳了，大家认出来了。我本来是认不出来的。就像它确实如此。它火了，你知道的，而且我想，你知道是什么吗？我觉得那是迈克尔·斯科特那种小男孩般的纯真热情真的透过整个屏幕散发出来，感染了一切。
midnight from the office. Someone sent me, um, touchdown dance. Someone did the scorn as a dance in the end zone and people recognized it. I wouldn't have recognized it. Like it does. It hits, you know, and I think, you know what it is? I think it's that Michael Scott Boyish enthusiasm actually leapt through the whole screen and everything.
就像那种极具传染力的迈克尔·斯科特能量。人们即使在现在也能感受到。而且有个橄榄球运动员感受得如此深刻，以至于他觉得，我懂。就是它。我要跳斯科恩舞。就在此时此刻，当我满身肾上腺素的时候，我要——这就是他脑子里想到的要去做的事。我记得那是因为那是对阵牛仔队的比赛，而且是一个对阵牛仔队的达阵。
Like that contagious Michael Scott energy. Just people got it even now. And a football player got it so much that he's like, I'm, I get it. I'm it. I'm going to do the scarring. And here at this moment when I'm full of adrenaline, I'm going to, that's the thing he thought of to do. I remember that because it was a game against the Cowboys and it was a touchdown against
绝不可能。是的。是的。所以我的，我的球队在那一刻落后，而接球员在跳斯科恩舞。那一定很痛苦。是的。是的。
the Cowboys. No way. Yes. Yes. So my, my team is, my team is losing in this moment and the receivers doing a, the scorn. That must have been painful. It was. Yeah.
我在网上看的时候，还有粉丝群体，他们为《午夜威胁级别》制作了自己的预告片。他们做了——我的意思是，粉丝们也用它做了一些非常酷的事情。是的。它确实有那种特质。我的意思是，这个名字太搞笑了。不是我起的名字，我忘了很久以前是谁起的名字了，但是，但“午夜威胁级别”这个名字，就好像它——
I was looking online and just also the fandom, they've made their own trailers for threat level midnight. They've done, I mean, fans have done some really cool stuff with it too. Yeah. It, it has that thing. I mean, the name is so funny. I didn't name it. I forget who did way back, but um, but the name threat level midnight, it's like it, it,
我上网看了一下，粉丝们也为《紧急程度午夜》制作了自己的预告片。他们做过，我的意思是，粉丝们也用它做了一些非常酷的事情。是的。它，它有那种特质。我的意思是，这个名字太搞笑了。不是我起的名字。我忘了很久以前是谁起的名字了，但是，嗯，但是“紧急程度午夜”这个名字，它就像，它，它，
it sounds right. It has the right ring to it for like a Sylvester Stallone 80s movie. But like, that's not a level midnight. Well, BJ, is there anything that we have not had a chance to discuss? The takeaway for me, besides how fun it is to talk about this is how similar talking about this with you too is to the spirit of threat level midnight, which is it really is about how much fun it was to do something when you were younger that you took so seriously. And we are very lucky in that, you know, we are just a, you know, little part of the hundreds
听起来挺对的。给人的感觉就像西尔维斯特·史泰龙的80年代动作片。但那个，不是最高危机。好吧，BJ，还有什么我们没机会讨论的事情吗？对我来说，除了聊这个有多好玩之外，最大的收获是，和你们俩聊这个的感觉，跟《最高危机》的精神非常相似——那就是当你年轻时，做一件你无比认真对待的事情，其实是件多么有趣的事。而我们真的很幸运，你知道的，我们只是……你知道的，创造了《办公室》辉煌的数百人中的一小部分，
of people who made the office, what it was, but we are very lucky that our thing is something that everyone validates as far and we're proud of. But I think that over time you realize, oh, that was my, that was my heart and soul in life no matter what anyone thought of it. And that is what Michael realizes. That is what I realized over time. I'm sure it's what you're realizing with your show. So the sort of threat level midnight was a trip down memory lane for the office writers
但我们非常幸运，我们的作品是一部大家都认可并引以为傲的作品。但我觉得随着时间的推移你会意识到，哦，无论别人怎么看，那都是我生命中的心血所在。而这正是迈克尔所意识到的。这也是我随着时间推移所意识到的。我敢肯定这也是你对你的节目所意识到的。所以《最高危机》对于《办公室》的编剧、演员和剧组来说，是一次记忆之旅。
and cast and crew. And it was a trip down memory lane for Michael Scott in a painful way for him because he had to confront his delusions of grandeur that he hadn't given up. So yeah, just talking about it with you, I feel like, I feel like Michael and Holly, you know, I feel like we're, we're doing that kind of thing. It's so fun. Oh, BJ, we love having you on the show, you're always so generous with us and it's just good to see you.
对迈克尔·斯科特来说，这也是一次充满痛苦的记忆之旅，因为他必须面对自己那些从未放弃过的宏大妄想。所以，是的，和你们聊这些，我觉得，我觉得迈克尔和霍莉，你知道的，我觉得我们也在做那种事情。太有趣了。哦，BJ，我们很高兴你能来节目，你对我们总是那么慷慨，见到你真好。
I love it. It's great to see you. Thank you, BJ. All right, see you soon. Love you. Thank you. Love you. Thanks, love you too.
我喜欢。很高兴见到你。谢谢你，BJ。好了，回头见。爱你们。谢谢。爱你们。谢谢，我也爱你们。
Bye. Bye. That was great talking to BJ. Always. Yes. Now it's time to break down this episode and Angela, I don't know about you, but I have so much. Look at this phone book I'm holding.
拜拜。拜拜。和BJ聊天太棒了。一如既往。是的。现在是时候剖析这一集了，安吉拉，我不知道你怎么样，但我有好多话要说。看看我手里这本电话簿。
So it's very thick. These are my notes. It's like 28 pages. I mean, it's threat level midnight. I know. All right. How does it open? Well, the scene opens with a delivery man named Archie.
它非常厚。这些是我的笔记。大概有28页。我是说，这可是《最高危机》。我知道。好吧。它是怎么开场的？嗯，这个场景开场时有一个名叫阿奇的送货员。
Did anyone else catch that? Is that Archie on a shirt? No. Well, I caught it. Look at this. We're already off to a great start. We have background catches. We have Archie.
有人注意到了吗？那件衬衫上印的是阿奇吗？没有。好吧，我注意到了。看这个。我们一开始就开了个好头。我们有背景彩蛋。我们有阿奇。
He's got a package for Michael. And guess what? There's going to be a shootout. There really is. Michael is going to win the shootout. He does like a robot dance. No, he's not doing a robot dance. He's doing like the Matrix, right?
他有个包裹要给迈克尔。你猜怎么着？要有一场枪战了。真的会有。迈克尔要在枪战中获胜。他跳了一段机器人舞。不，他没有跳机器人舞。他是在模仿《黑客帝国》，对吧？
He's being like Neo. Yes, Angela Keanu. Did you not get this? Yes. What do you mean yes? I did. You said robot dance. Of course.
他在模仿尼奥。是的，安吉拉，基努。你没看出来吗？是的。你说的“是”是什么意思？我看出来了。你刚才说机器人舞。当然了。
I caught it. I mean, you were just so excited. Look at you. You're having a moment because you're like, I caught the Matrix reference. Oh, my God, I'm letting you have a moment. Letting me have a moment? I don't believe you. I don't think you caught it.
我看出来了。我是说，你当时太激动了。看看你。你正沉浸在自己的小世界里，因为你在想，我抓住了《黑客帝国》的梗。天哪，我让你沉浸一会儿。让我沉浸一会儿？我才不信。我觉得你根本没看出来。
Bitch. Look at my notes. What? What is happening today? Look at my notes. Okay. Okay. Her notes do say, I sensed a little bit of the Matrix in this scene.
拜托。看看我的笔记。什么？今天到底怎么了？看看我的笔记。好吧。好吧。她的笔记上确实写着：“我在这场戏里感觉到了一点《黑客帝国》的影子。”
When Neo dodges the agent's fire when he's on top of the building, that is what Angela wrote down. Here's one of Jenna's phrases that I love. Just when someone crosses the line with her, she goes, you're going to want to back that up. And that's how I felt when you were like, did you not catch that? Of course I caught that. All right.
当尼奥在楼顶上躲避特工的枪击时，这就是安吉拉写下来的。这是詹娜的一句我非常喜欢的话。每当有人触碰她的底线时，她就会说：“你最好把刚才的话收回。”当你们说“你没看出来吗”的时候，我就是这种感觉。我当然看出来了。好吧。
Well, I'm going to have to back that up. You caught it. Thank goodness. I would have been confused. Okay. We can continue being friends now. We can. There is no spoon.
好吧，那我得把这话收回了。你看出来了。谢天谢地。我还挺纳闷的。好吧。我们现在可以继续做朋友了。我们可以。汤匙是不存在的。
Well, we had a fan question from Kendall T and Durham, Maine, who asked, who plays the delivery man that Michael Skarn shoots at the beginning of the episode? Archie. Yes, Archie. So the actor who played Archie was an actor named Greg Collins, who Randy Cordray pitched for the role because the actor who was originally scripted to play this part was not available. Michael Norton. Michael Norton, Michael's improv teacher from email surveillance.
好吧，我们收到了来自缅因州达勒姆的肯德尔·T的粉丝提问，他问：在剧集开头迈克尔·斯坎向其开枪的送货员是谁扮演的？阿奇。是的，阿奇。扮演阿奇的演员是一个名叫格雷格·科林斯的演员，兰迪·科德雷推荐他扮演这个角色，因为原本剧本安排扮演这个角色的演员没有档期。迈克尔·诺顿。迈克尔·诺顿，来自《电子邮件监控》一集中迈克尔的即兴表演老师。
I'm sorry, but that would have been amazing. That would have been so funny. I mean, that's the guy who took away Michael's pretend guns and improv class. Also, you guys, if you ever get a chance to see Michael Norton on stage, he's so hilarious. Well, I thought Greg Collins did a wonderful job. He did. He was perfect. He even looked how I thought a delivery guy in this type of movie would look.
不好意思，但那一定绝了。那肯定超级搞笑。我是说，那就是在即兴表演课上没收了迈克尔假枪的那个人。还有，伙计们，如果你们有机会在舞台上看到迈克尔·诺顿，他超级搞笑。好吧，我觉得格雷格·科林斯表现得很棒。他确实很棒。他堪称完美。他甚至长得就像我想象中这种电影里的送货员的样子。
Yes. Did you notice that 41 seconds his shirt is unbuttoned all of a sudden? No, I didn't. Was that to show the blood? Yes. So he had like a navy button up and then all of a sudden at 41 seconds, it's unbuttoned. I love that. Randy said that the guns were dummy guns.
是的。你有没有注意到在41秒的时候他的衬衫突然解开了扣子？不，我没注意到。那是为了展示血迹吗？是的。所以他穿了一件海军蓝的衬衫，然后突然在41秒时，扣子解开了。我喜欢这个细节。兰迪说那些枪都是道具枪。
They held no ammunition and they put all the sound effects and the muzzle flashes in during post-production. I watched that scene knowing that it was done in post-production and I kind of couldn't believe it. That is wild because you could see Steve as Michael kind of flinching, you know? I know. He did the kickback. That's some good, fakey kickback acting.
它们没有子弹，所有的音效和枪口焰都是在后期制作时加上去的。我看着那个场景，明知那是后期制作的，却还是有点不敢相信。这太疯狂了，因为你能看到作为迈克尔的史蒂夫似乎在畏缩，你知道吗？我知道。他做出了后坐力反应。这假装后坐力反弹的演技真不错。
It really was. We also had a fan question from Maddu P. in Toronto, Canada, who says, I immediately recognized the music from the Born Identity when I first watched this episode. How much did it cost to get the rights? Well, I'm impressed that you spotted that. It was the Born Identity. It was scripted. Randy Cordray said it cost $25,000 to get that.
确实如此。我们还收到了来自加拿大多伦多的马杜·P的粉丝提问，他说：我第一次看这一集时，立刻听出了《谍影重重》的音乐。买下版权花了他多少钱？好吧，你能听出来，我很佩服你。那就是《谍影重重》。剧本里就是这么写的。兰迪·科德雷说买下它花了两万五千美元。
BJ said he thought Michael Scott would have pirated it off of like a DVD he had. Totally. Right? Yeah. Well, at the end of the scene, Michael's going to say, clean up on all five. We talked about this with BJ. I went to the table read draft of the script and they had two phrases from the very beginning. It made it all the way to the shooting draft and it was recorded, but they ultimately went
BJ说他觉得迈克尔·斯科特会从他有的某种DVD上盗版下来。完全有可能。对吧？是的。好吧，在场景的结尾，迈克尔要说：“5号过道需要清理。”我们跟BJ聊过这个。我看了剧本的剧本围读初稿，他们从最开始就有两句台词。它一直保留到了拍摄剧本中，而且也录制了，但他们最终还是选择
with clean up on all five. The other one was return to sender. It even made it into the bloopers. I think we should hear it. Return to sender. Clean up on all five. Okay, so clearly clean up on all five is the thing that made everyone crack up and that's how it won.
用了“5号过道需要清理”。另一句是“退回寄件人”。它甚至还被收录进了NG镜头里。我觉得我们应该听听看。退回寄件人。5号过道需要清理。好吧，很显然“5号过道需要清理”是那句让所有人都笑场并最终胜出的台词。
It seems like it. Doesn't it? Yeah. And then Michael has this talking head where he says, after three years of writing, one year of shooting, four years of reshooting, and two years of editing, I have finally completed my movie, Threat Level Midnight. Jenna, it took Michael Scott and you and I the same amount of time to write something. Are you talking about our book?
看起来是这样的。不是吗？是的。然后迈克尔有一段对着镜头的独白，他说：经过三年的剧本创作、一年的拍摄、四年的补拍以及两年的剪辑，我终于完成了我的电影——《最高危机》。詹娜，迈克尔·斯科特和你花在写东西上的时间是一样的。你是在说我们的书吗？
Yes, it took us three years and seven months. We had to write our book. So the episode begins with Erin making an announcement in the bullpen. Michael is with her. She says Threat Level Midnight is complete and Michael's willing to watch it with everyone, but only if everyone is dying to see it. The Jim and Pam talking head is so good. We are so giddy.
是的，我们花了三年零七个月。我们不得不写我们的书。所以这一集开始时，艾琳在办公区大厅发布了一个通知。迈克尔和她在一起。她说《最高危机》完成了，迈克尔愿意和大家一起看，但前提是所有人都极度渴望看。吉姆和帕姆的镜头前独白太棒了。我们当时太晕头转向了。
You're so giddy. Also, when I rewatched this, I thought John looked a little sweaty throughout this episode. What? I don't know, I don't know if I was really tired. As Golden Face or as Jim? As Jim. In the bullpen, I was like, I wonder if it was a hot day. I even went to the shooting draft to see the week we filmed it, to see the date.
你们太晕头转向了。还有，当我重看这一集时，我觉得约翰在这一整集里看起来都有点出汗。什么？我不知道，我不知道我是不是真的很累。作为金面人还是作为吉姆？作为吉姆。在大厅里，我在想，我不知道那天是不是很热。我甚至去翻了拍摄剧本，看我们拍摄的那周，看具体的日期。
I was like, oh, I bet it was in the summer. No, it was January, but JK, you look a little sweaty. I wonder what that was about, just him? I thought so. Sorry, JK. I just thought you had a little bit of a glow. He had a glow. He had a glow.
我在想，哦，我敢打赌那是在夏天。不，那是在一月，但JK，你看起来确实有点出汗。我不知道那是怎么回事，只有他这样吗？我是这么觉得的。对不起，JK。我只是觉得你身上有点光芒。他自带光芒。他自带光芒。
Alright. So, Michael, they definitely want to watch the movie and after he leaves, she gives the bullpen a little pep talk to set the right mood for watching this movie, kind of a mom speech. Oh, yeah. She says, so let's stay positive and no laughing, no comments, just positive energy and we'll have a pure fun day, okay? And Creed's like, thanks, mom.
好的。所以，迈克尔，他们绝对想看这部电影，在他离开后，她给大厅里的所有人做了一个小小的鼓舞士气的演讲，为观看这部电影营造合适的气氛，有点像妈妈的演讲。哦，是的。她说：所以我们要保持积极心态，不要笑，不要发表评论，只要有积极的能量，我们就会度过纯粹有趣的一天，好吗？然后克里德说：谢谢，妈妈。
Everyone's really excited. They start to gather in the conference room. Phyllis is going to bring in some popcorn and Holly did not know that Michael had made a movie and he's really excited for her to see it and she says, I can't wait. The first shot of the film is a picture of the exterior of Skarn Mansion and we got a fan question from Davina Kay in Illinois who said, in looking at the main image of Skarn Manor in the movie, you can see in the bottom right hand corner of the screen a small picture of Carol's face.
大家都非常兴奋。他们开始聚集在会议室里。菲利斯拿来了一些爆米花，而霍莉并不知道迈克尔拍了一部电影，他非常高兴能让她看到，她说：我等不及了。电影的第一个镜头是斯坎豪宅外观的照片，我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州达维娜·K的粉丝提问，她说：在电影中看斯坎庄园的主画面时，你可以在屏幕的右下角看到一张卡罗尔脸部的小照片。
Did Michael use an image of one of Carol's real estate listings? Yes. Yes. Yes, that is exactly what he did. Randy said that this image of this house was actually a stock photo and we brought in Nancy Corell and took a picture of her and Michael Gallenberg added it to the bottom of that photo. Yes.
迈克尔用了卡罗尔的一张房地产房源照片吗？是的。是的。是的，他就是这么干的。兰迪说这座房子的照片实际上是一张库存照片，我们把南希·卡瑞尔请来拍了张照片，然后迈克尔·盖伦伯格把它加到了那张照片的底部。是的。
Well, like I said, there is a DVD commentary for this episode and Charlie, Randy shared that there was a lot of debate in the writer's room about the size of this house that they used for Michael Skarn's Manor because they wanted it to be a house realistically that Carol would be showing in this area. It did look like a mansion, definition of a mansion. It did and the address is 451 Hanover Lane, Clark Summit, Pennsylvania. I looked it up. I couldn't find a house.
好吧，就像我说的，这一集有DVD评论音轨，查理，兰迪分享说，编剧室里曾就是否使用这栋房子作为迈克尔·斯坎的庄园展开了激烈的辩论，因为他们希望这是一栋卡罗尔在这个地区展示时看起来很真实的房子。它确实看起来像一座豪宅，豪宅的定义。确实如此，地址是宾夕法尼亚州克拉克萨米特汉诺威巷451号。我查过了。我没找到房子。
Oh, we made it up, maybe so. Now we're going to see a montage of news clippings. Well here's the director's trying to tell you a backstory, guys. So then we see a bunch of magazine covers announcing Michael Skarn's marriage to Catherine Zeta and then the announcement of her death at the hands of Golden Face. We had a fan question from Kristen M from Cedar Falls, Iowa who said, did Catherine Zeta-Jones have to give her permission to be featured in this episode? Did she get paid as a guest star?
哦，那是我们瞎编的，也许吧。现在我们要看一个新闻剪辑蒙太奇。好吧，导演这是在试着告诉你们一个背景故事，伙计们。所以我们看到了一堆宣布迈克尔·斯坎与凯瑟琳·泽塔结婚的杂志封面，接着是宣布她在金面人手下丧生的讣告。我们收到了来自艾奥瓦州锡达福尔斯的克里斯滕·M的粉丝提问，她说：凯瑟琳·泽塔-琼斯必须授权才能在本集中出场吗？她作为客串演员拿片酬了吗？
Actually no. We did not pay her or ask her permission. Was it like a stock photo? It was a stock photo that we bought from the photographer for $790. And then Michael Gallenberg took a picture of Steve dressed in a tuxedo and then that's how they made the picture. Well, it's a very good picture. I thought she looked beautiful.
其实并没有。我们既没有付钱给她，也没有征求她的同意。那就像是一张库存照片吗？那是我们从摄影师那里以790美元买的一张库存照片。然后迈克尔·盖伦伯格拍了一张史蒂夫穿燕尾服的照片，他们就是这样合成那张照片的。好吧，这是一张非常好的照片。我觉得她看起来很漂亮。
And you know, she was excited. Her family is a fan of the office and she even came on our podcast for the client and read our summary. And we had a huge cut out of her that we put next to us when we recorded because she had to send in an audio clip, but it was like she was right in the room with us. It was our first A-list guest. I think so. Yeah.
而且你知道吗，她当时很兴奋。她的家人是《办公室》的粉丝，她甚至为了《客户》那一集上了我们的播客，还读了我们的总结。我们有一个她的人形立牌，录音时就把它放在我们旁边，因为她不得不发来一段音频剪辑，但感觉她就像和我们同处一室一样。这是我们的第一个A咖嘉宾。我想是的。是的。
Even though she was a cut out. That's right. Well, now we're going to find Skarn, face down in bed, bottle of booze. His butler is going to be waking him, holding a very elaborate silver tray, very fancy breakfast tray. Did anyone else think Michael Skarn laying face down like that with like a little nod to major league? Or that opening sequence where they go and find Tom Berenger and he's like, face down
尽管她只是个人形立牌。没错。好吧，现在我们要找到斯坎，他趴在床上，身边放着一瓶酒。他的管家将要叫醒他，手里托着一个非常精致的银托盘，一个非常高级的早餐盘。有没有人觉得迈克尔·斯坎那样趴着，有点在向《大联盟》致敬的意思？或者说那段开场镜头，他们去找汤姆·贝伦杰，他也是那样
with some booze. No one else. Remember major league? Come on. I do. And yes. Thank you. Oh, wasn't it exactly the same?
趴着，旁边放着酒。只有我吗？还记得《大联盟》吗？拜托。我记得。还有，是的。谢谢。哦，难道不是一模一样吗？
Yes. Thank you. Well, I noticed that Steve's face was all scruffy when he wakes up. He's been on a bender. He's not making good choices. Well, Randy said that in order to get that scruffy look, they had to put a note on the call sheet reminding him not to shave before coming to work because Steve would always shave before coming to work.
是的。谢谢。好吧，我注意到史蒂夫醒来时满脸胡渣。他一直在纵情狂欢。他做出了不明智的选择。嗯，兰迪说为了呈现那种满脸胡渣的外观，他们不得不在通告单上贴便条提醒他上班前不要刮胡子，因为史蒂夫总是会在上班前刮胡子。
And they had a little note that said, Steve, don't shave. Don't shave. I have a question. What is it? What was Michael's budget for this movie? I don't know, but he made it over a very long period of time. He did, but we're about to be in the Oval Office. We've already seen what his condo looks like.
他们留了一个小纸条上面写着：史蒂夫，别刮胡子。别刮胡子。我有个问题。什么问题？迈克尔拍这部电影的预算是多少？我不知道，但他花了很长一段时间才把它拍完。他确实拍了很久，但我们马上就要进入椭圆形办公室了。我们已经看过他的公寓是什么样子的了。
It's candelabras and silver trays and whatnot, but this Oval Office, which is supposed to be, I'm guessing, the conference room. Yes. It is the conference room, and you can even see reception through the door when the shot is on Michael and Dwight, or I'm sorry, on Michael and Samuel, Samuel. Did you see what was outside the window behind President Jackson? What? Cherry blossoms.
里面有烛台、银托盘之类的东西，但这个椭圆形办公室，我猜应该是会议室假扮的。是的。这就是会议室，当镜头对着迈克尔和德怀特，或者抱歉，对着迈克尔和塞缪尔、塞缪尔时，你甚至可以通过门看到前台。你看到杰克逊总统身后的窗户外面是什么了吗？什么？樱花。
It was amazing. Our set dressing team was incredible. I didn't know where we were when the scene started until we reversed the shot, but they put one of those like, fakey, light box, window things behind him. It was amazing. Michael put that there. Yes. Annie hung the elaborate curtains, and he got the sculptures and all the paintings.
太惊艳了。我们的布景团队太不可思议了。当场景开始时，我甚至不知道我们在哪儿，直到我们转换了镜头视角，他们在他的身后放了一个那种假的、带灯箱的窗户布景。太棒了。那是迈克尔弄的。是的。安妮挂上了精致的窗帘，他还弄来了雕塑和所有的画作。
Did you catch the address of the White House? 1600 Pennsylvania Avenue? Washington, DC, DC. Oh, Dwight did not. Washington, DC, DC. Well in this scene, the President is going to explain that Skarn's old enemy, Golden Face, is planning to bomb the NHL All-Star Game, and he's also taken hostages. Now this is really personal for the President because he owns the stadium.
你注意到白宫的地址了吗？宾夕法尼亚大道1600号？华盛顿特区，特区。哦，德怀特没有注意到。华盛顿特区，特区。嗯，在这场戏里，总统将要解释说，斯坎的老敌人金面人计划轰炸NHL全明星赛，而且他还劫持了人质。这事对总统来说真的很私人，因为他拥有这个体育场。
It's his retirement plan. I know. That's what the President is going to retire doing, is owning this one stadium. Skarn can't decide if he's going to take this job on or not, so he's got to flip a coin seven times. Best out of seven. And he doesn't edit around that. You're going to see all seven coin flips.
这是他的退休计划。我知道。这就是总统退休后要做的事，就是拥有这一个体育场。斯坎无法决定自己是否要接下这桩差事，所以他必须连抛七次硬币。七局三胜。而且他把这个过程原封不动地剪了进去。你会看到全部七次抛硬币的画面。
That's right. So something BJ said in an interview that I thought was so funny, because there is an obsession with All-Star Games in this movie. He said he thought that Michael Scott would view an All-Star Game as the most important event in sports, even though in real life they're kind of irrelevant. It's more about the championship game. Yes. He said he also liked that Golden Face had a thing for All-Star Games, and he had previously
没错。所以BJ在一次采访中说过一句话，我觉得太搞笑了，因为在这部电影里有一种对全明星赛的执念。他说他认为迈克尔·斯科特会把全明星赛看作体育界最重要的赛事，尽管在现实生活中它们其实有点无关紧要。人们更看重冠军赛。是的。他说他也喜欢金面人对全明星赛情有独钟，他之前还
blown up the WNBA All-Star Game, which is how Catherine Zeta Skarn died. Did anyone else catch up four minutes and 10 seconds that Darryl is clean shaven? I did. Mm-hmm. It's the first time we've seen Darryl without facial hair. Ever. It's the first episode of The Office. We got a fan question from Peter G in Poland who said, did the writers have to plan out
炸毁了WNBA全明星赛，凯瑟琳·泽塔·斯坎就是那样死的。有没有人在4分10秒时发现达里尔把胡子刮得精光？我发现了。嗯哼。这是我们第一次看到达里尔没有面部毛发。有史以来第一次。这是《办公室》的第一集。我们收到了来自波兰的彼得·G的粉丝提问，他说：编剧们是否必须为迈克尔的电影进度表规划出一个理论上的时间线，以便发型和服装能与之契合？
a theoretical timeline for Michael's film schedules so that hair and wardrobe could represent it? For example, in addition to the fact that Darryl is clean shaven, I noticed that we see Jim and Pam's season one and two hairstyle. Kelly has her updo. Oh, yeah. Angela has her braid from the early days. I can only imagine the amount of planning and wardrobe meetings.
例如，除了达里尔刮了胡子之外，我注意到我们看到了吉姆和帕姆第一季和第二季的发型。凯莉梳着盘发。哦，是的。安吉拉保留着早期那种小辫子。我简直无法想象这其中需要多少策划和服装会议。
Oh, yes. This was the whole thing. Just speaking of Darryl, Randy said that we had to pick up some Darryl work from a previous episode, and hair and makeup had to add back a fake-like mustache goatee for Darryl to match at one point. Oh, yeah. Craig talked about this on the DVD commentary. I think it was a big thing for him.
哦，是的。这可是一项大工程。说到达里尔，兰迪说我们不得不补拍一些达里尔在之前剧集里的戏份，发型和化妆团队不得不给达里尔重新粘上一个假的小胡子和山羊胡，以便在某个画面中对上。哦，是的。克雷格在DVD评论音轨里谈过这个。我想这对来说他是一件大事。
He did not want to shave, and BJ really insisted on it. I guess BJ wanted the character that Darryl plays, President Jackson, to be distinct in time from Darryl Philbin. But that meant he had to get this weird, fake-y beard in between as they cut back and forth. BJ also shared that they had to glue sideburns onto his face. I didn't even notice that. Yeah. You know where you can really see it?
他不想刮胡子，而BJ非常坚持要他刮。我猜BJ希望达里尔扮演的角色——杰逊总统——在时间线上能和达里尔·菲尔宾区分开来。但这意味著在镜头切来切去的时候，他不得不弄上这个奇怪的假胡子。BJ还分享说，他们不得不把鬓角粘到他的脸上。我甚至都没注意到这一点。是的。你知道在哪儿能真切地看出来吗？
Well, first of all, if you go to one minute and 55 seconds, you can see it. But then later in the episode, when he's on the ice skating rink, is when I really saw it. Oh, okay. Yeah, fake-y sideburns. Well, we all know Michael's going to take the job. He didn't need to flip the coin seven times. No.
首先，如果你看到1分55秒，你就能看出来。但后来在这一集中，当他在溜冰场上时，那才是我真正看到的时候。哦，好吧。是的，假鬓角。好吧，我们都知道迈克尔会接下这份工作。他根本不需要抛七次硬币。不用。
Clean up on aisle five. Clean up on aisle five, guys. We are now going to the stadium where the hostages are being held. And we meet Golden Face, played by Jim, also a very giddy John Krasinski, who wanted the gold makeup. He was excited to become Golden Face. You have no idea how excited John was to film Threat Level Midnight. All of it.
5号过道需要清理。5号过道需要清理，伙计们。我们现在要去关押人质的体育场了。我们见到了金面人，由吉姆扮演，这也是一个极其兴奋的约翰·卡拉辛斯基，他想要金色的妆容。他对成为金面人感到兴奋。你根本不知道约翰拍摄《最高危机》时有多兴奋。所有的戏份都是。
Later we're going to get to that skating scene where he's in that just ridiculous skating outfit with the gold face. He was so on board for all of it, and you can see it in his performance. It is so incredibly charming and fun. John's performance as Golden Face is one of my favorite parts of Threat Level Midnight. At the same time, John is going to have a talking head where he said obviously he didn't love the dialogue of Golden Face. He didn't love saying that he was going to dig up Skarn's wife and hump her real good.
稍后我们会看到那个滑冰的场景，他穿着那套荒谬的滑冰服，脸上涂着金色。他对这一切都全力以赴，你从他的表演中就能看出来。这真的是难以置信的迷人和有趣。约翰对金面人的演绎是我在《最高危机》中最喜欢的片段之一。与此同时，约翰有一段镜头前的独白，他说他显然不喜欢金面人的台词。他不喜欢说他要挖出斯坎妻子的坟并狠狠地操她。
But he obviously took the part to impress a receptionist. This scene was longer. It's in the extended cut that's on the DVD. I remember it. It's amazing. Yeah. So Golden Face leaves. And when he does, the hostages quickly are like, we've got to pick a leader.
但他显然接下这个角色是为了给前台留下深刻印象。这个场景原本更长。它在DVD的加长剪辑版里。我还记得。太棒了。是的，金面人离开了。当他离开后，人质们迅速开始说：我们得选个领队。
I went to the shooting draft as well because I wanted to read it. Roy says, we need to choose a leader, someone tough enough to take on Golden Face. And Pam says, I can be the leader. Kevin's like, you, what makes you so tough? And Pam says, I have experience as a leader, a negotiator, a general, and a cop. In other words, I'm a mom. I remember that line. Everyone smiles and nods.
我也去翻了拍摄剧本，因为我想读一下。罗伊说：我们需要选一个领队，一个足够强硬能对付金面人的人。帕姆说：我可以当领队。凯文说：你？是什么让你觉得你这么强硬？帕姆说：我有当领队、谈判专家、将军和警察的经验。换句话说，我是一个妈妈。我还记得那句台词。大家都微笑着点头。
Toby puts his hand on Pam's leg and says, yeah, it'll be Sandra. That was your character's name. So then Golden Face is going to re-enter and Pam goes, gulp. I remember that too. Jenna, you had to do that gulp so many times because you guys kept laughing and it's in the bloopers and I want you to hear it. So have you chosen a leader yet? Gulp.
托比把手放在帕姆的腿上说：行吧，那就叫桑德拉。那是你角色的名字。然后金面人重新登场，帕姆做了一个“咕咚”咽口水的动作。我也记得那个！詹娜，你得做那个咽口水的动作好多次，因为你们一直在笑，这被收录进了NG镜头里，我想让你们听听。所以你们选好领队了吗？咕咚。
So broad. Gulp. Don't look at me. Gulp. I mean, oh, that was fun. I remember so that was shot in the warehouse. You can probably tell they tried to dress it as if we were behind the scenes at a hockey stadium, but I have strong memories of shooting those scenes.
太夸张了。咕咚。别看着我。咕咚。我是说，哦，太好玩了。我记得那是仓库里拍的。你们可能看得出来，他们试图把那里装扮成我们身处曲棍球场幕后的样子，但我对拍摄那些场景有着深刻的记忆。
There's a few others in the bloopers too. It looked like you guys were having a lot of fun. There's one that I can't play because it's all visual, but Brian is Kevin has to stand up, but his hands are tied and he kind of flops over on you guys as he tries to get up and it's so funny. Well big twist in the plot is coming up. Skarn finds out that the all-star game is sold out and the only way he's going to be able to get in is to be a player in the game.
NG镜头里还有一些其他的片段。看起来你们当时玩得很开心。有一个片段我没法播，因为全都是视觉画面，布莱恩饰演的凯文必须站起来，但他的双手被绑着，当他试图站起来时，他整个人扑倒在你们身上，超级搞笑。剧情的重大转折就要来了。斯坎发现全明星赛门票已经售罄，他能进去的唯一办法就是成为比赛的一名球员。
But he doesn't know how to skate. And that's when we meet Cherokee Jack. You know that Creed's part of Cherokee Jack was initially scripted to be Idris Elba? No way. Yes, but we couldn't get him. He was filming a movie in like Hungary or something. Did Randy tell you that? I didn't know that.
但他不会滑冰。就在这时，我们遇到了切诺基·杰克。你们知道克里德饰演的切诺基·杰克最初剧本里是定由伊德里斯·艾尔巴出演的吗？不会吧。是的，但我们没能请到他。他当时在匈牙利什么的国家拍电影。兰迪告诉你的吗？我不知道这件事。
Yeah. Randy said that the logistics of getting Idris on an international flight for one day of shooting in Van Is was, quote, too big a hurdle to overcome. So BJ pivoted. He rewrote the part for Creed, which I love. Oh my God, I loved everything about it. I loved his tassel jacket. It's very karate kid.
是的。兰迪说，把伊德里斯弄上一架国际航班，只在温哥华拍一天的戏，后勤上的难度“太大了，无法克服”。所以BJ转换了思路。他为克里德重写了这个角色，我太爱了。天哪，我爱死这里的一切了。我爱极了他的流苏夹克。这非常有《龙威小子》的感觉。
You got to mop the ice. Mop the ice. Why do I have to mop the ice? You'll see. We also got a fan question from Angie in Birmingham, Alabama, who said, what is the song that is playing while Michael is mopping the ice? Angie, that is the Billy Joel song running on ice. Randy said it cost us $40,000 for that song and that montage of Michael doing his bow flex
你得擦冰面。擦冰面。我为什么要擦冰面？你会知道的。我们还收到了来自阿拉巴马州伯明翰的安吉的粉丝提问，她问：迈克尔在擦冰面时放的是什么歌？安吉，那是比利·乔尔的歌《在冰上奔跑》。兰迪说这首歌花掉了我们4万美元，迈克尔做弓步器训练和擦冰面的那个蒙太奇也是。
and mopping the ice. Steve doing the bow flexes in the bloopers. There's no music. You know, they added the music later. It looks like they're like throwing water on him. I don't know. But he's going and he just cracks himself up. I also noticed there are really good figure skaters skating behind Michael as he's learning
史蒂夫在NG镜头里做弓步训练时是没有音乐的。你知道的，音乐是后来加进去的。看起来他们像是在往他身上泼水。我不知道。但他一边做一边把自己逗得哈哈大笑。我还注意到，在迈克尔学滑冰的时候，他身后有真正的高水平花样滑冰运动员在滑冰。我也看到了。
to skate. I saw that as well. Next up, our director, Michael, is going to do that classic thing that happens in movies where they show a passage of time with this calendar, right? Mm-hmm. The dates are falling on the ground. It's one of those page a day tear off calendars. Well, it was a Dave Berry calendar and BJ told us that Dave Berry was a favorite of his
接下来，我们的导演迈克尔要用那种电影里经典的套路，通过日历来展示时间的流逝，对吧？嗯哼。那些日期掉在了地上。那是那种每日撕历。好吧，这是一本戴夫·巴里的日历，BJ告诉我们戴夫·巴里是他成长时期最喜欢的人，他非常喜欢他的喜剧。他会在夏令营里大声朗读戴夫的书来逗笑其他孩子。所以他非常高兴能让这本日历成为《最高危机》的一部分。
in his formative years and he loved his comedy. He would read Dave's books out loud at summer camps to make other kids laugh. And so he was really excited to have this calendar be part of threat level midnight. I love that. I love imagining BJ at summer camp reading a Dave Berry book to the other campers. It's so cute. Randy also shared with us that when they reached out to Dave Berry's legal representation to see if they could use his calendar, his assistant Judy Smith was a huge fan of the
我喜欢这样。我喜欢想象BJ在夏令营里给其他营员朗读戴夫·巴里的书。太可爱了。兰迪还跟我们分享说，当他们联系戴夫·巴里的法律代表看是否能使用他的日历时，他的助手朱迪·史密斯是这个节目的超级粉丝。这总是有帮助的。是的，戴夫当时不在城里，但朱迪找到了他，获得了他的许可。所以兰迪说，非常感谢朱迪·史密斯帮助我们促成了这件事。
show. That always helps. Yes, Dave was out of town, but Judy tracked him down, got his permission. So Randy said, a big thank you to Judy Smith for helping us make this happen. And on the commentary, Charlie shared that Dave Berry also sent in a letter to the writers and an autographed photograph of himself and the writers hung it in the writer's room. That is so cool. That must have been such a weird full circle moment for BJ.
而在评论音轨中，查理分享说，戴夫·巴里还给编剧们寄了一封信和一张他自己的亲笔签名照片，编剧们把它挂在了编剧室里。太酷了。对于BJ来说，这一定是一个奇妙的圆满时刻。我知道。呃。我能打断我们的剖析一秒钟，跟你们说一件非常“信息过载”的事吗？怎么了？我穿着一件新胸罩。我想买新胸罩来着。我很喜欢。太棒了。
I know. Ugh. Can I interrupt our breakdown for one quick second to tell you what a TMI thing. What's going on? I'm wearing a new bra. I wanted to get new bras. And I love it. It's great.
是个叫notary的牌子，我新了解到的牌子。我左边的胸部现在有点从杯里掉出来了。也没有完全掉出来，但就是露出来更多一点。我能感觉到它没有得到对称的支撑。我觉得可能是我买小了一个尺码。你需要……好吧，我们知道你胸围很大。你需要托着它吗？
It's a notary, the brand that I learned about. My left boob is kind of falling out of the cup right now. It's not completely falling out, but it's more out. And I can just feel that it's not symmetrically supported. I think maybe I got too small a size. Do you need to? Well, we know you have a big wrack. Do you need to hold it?
我不是那个意思。我是说，我觉得我没有，你知道的，我本来不想……你需要做个“聚拢”的动作吗？不，我不知道。我已经试着聚拢过了。我看见你在扭来扭去。我不知道发生什么事了。我知道。
I wasn't trying to say it like that. I'm saying, I think I didn't, you know, I didn't want to take that. Do you need to do the scoop? No, I don't know. I've tried scooping it. I saw you fidgeting. I didn't know what was happening. I know.
我知道。我当时想再扭动一下，但我开始对不停地扯我左边的胸罩带子感到不好意思了。但问题是，我没有多走那一步，让那个拿着软尺的女士帮我量正确的胸罩尺码，因为我不想麻烦。现在我觉得我买错了尺码。但它其他方面我都挺喜欢的。
I know. And that was the thing I wanted to fidget again, but I was getting self-conscious about constantly tugging at my left boob. But here's the thing. I didn't do the extra step of having the lady with the tape measure help measure me for the correct bra size because I didn't want to deal with it. And now I think I bought the wrong size. But everything else about it I like.
就是我没有对称的罩杯支撑、胸部支撑。现在有两件事在我脑子里闪过。一是左边不合适，但右边合适。对。左边更大？左边一直都比右边大。好吧。
It's just I don't have symmetrical cup support, boob support. Two things are going through my mind right now. One is that the left side doesn't fit, but the right side does. Yeah. Correct. Left side bigger? Left side's always been bigger. Okay.
它在心脏上方。我觉得实际上左乳比右乳大其实挺常见的。卡西？没有，我从来没有让人好好测量过。好吧。好吧。我脑子里闪过的另一件事是。
It's over my heart. And I think that's actually really common that your left breast is larger than your right. Cassie? No, I've never gotten them properly measured. Okay. Okay. Here's my other thing that's going through my mind.
我去做了乳腺钼靶检查。你们这些家伙，我一直拖着不去。詹娜狠狠地数落了我一顿。她说：大姐，是时候了。去做了吧。我很不擅长那种事。我不擅长预约医生。所以我去了。
I went to get my mammogram. You guys, I've been putting it off. Jenna fussed at me hardcore. She's like, lady, it is time. Go do it. I'm bad about that stuff. I'm bad about making doctor's appointments. So I went.
我太骄傲了。你去了。我为你感到骄傲。我给你发了信息。我要去做我那该死的钼靶检查了。我进去了。我穿上了前面开口的小粉袍，你知道的。她从钼靶检查的地方给我发了一张照片。
I was so proud. You did. I was so proud of you. I texted you. I'm going to get my flip and mammogram. I went in there. I put on the little pink robe, you know, that opens in the front. She sent me a photo from the mammogram place.
穿着袍子？说要开始了。听着，你们应该为我感到骄傲。那个女士，她叫阿什利。她说：走到机器前，把脸转向左边，先做右边胸部，把脸转向左边，我要把你的右胸拿过来，放在这个类似金属托盘的东西上。然后我要按这个按钮，它会把它压扁，但我需要你
In the robe? Saying it's happening. Look, you should be proud of me. The lady, her name was Ashley. She said, step up to the machine, turn your cheek to the left, did my right boob first, turn your cheek to the left, I'm going to take your right boob, I'm going to put it on this like metal tray. And then I'm going to hit this button and it's going to compress it, but I need you
身体靠上去，把我的胸部压扁，然后我得忍住，接着所有的灯都闪烁了，一切都停了下来，机器就在我的右胸夹在里面的时候坏了。机器坏了。他们按了一个按钮，释放了我的胸部，然后那位女士说：我不知道，我不知道刚刚发生了什么。我不知道电脑是不是死机了。然后屏幕显示紧急关机。你的胸部把钼靶机器弄坏了。
to lean into it, squished my boob and then I had to hold it and then all the lights flickered and everything stopped and the machine broke with my right boob in it. The machine broke. They hit a button, released my boob and then the lady was like, I don't, I don't know what just happened. I don't know that the computer's frozen. And then it said emergency shut down. Your boob broke the mammogram machine.
这就是个笑话。护士有点像是在说：反正你的胸部把它弄坏了。所以他们修不好机器，然后我就走了，我就走了。所以你看，乔治总开玩笑说，每当我靠近任何种类的电子设备时，它都会短路。也许我把胸部“钨化”了。我希望大家今天都喜欢这两个关于胸部的故事。好吧，这只是詹娜的左胸太大了，而我的右胸有超能力。
This was the joke. The nurse kind of was like, your boob broke it anyway. So they couldn't fix the machine and I left, I left. So there you go, Josh kind of jokes that whenever I get around like any kind of electrical device, it shortens out. Like maybe I've tungstened, maybe I've tungstened my boobs. I hope everyone enjoyed these two boob stories today. Well, it was just Jenna's left boob is too big and my right boob has superpowers.
所以，真是太神奇了。好吧，我们大概应该回到这一集了。有一场非常激烈的决斗马上就要上演了。哦天哪，我太期待那场冰上决斗了。太精彩了。这场决斗里有三位选手，斯坎，然后是一个穿着全黑西装戴着白色面具的家伙，还有一个穿着全蓝衣服的家伙。我永远也忘不了奥斯卡穿那套蓝西装的样子。
So what, what an amazing thing. Well we should probably get back to this episode. There's a very intense skate off that's about to happen. Oh my gosh, I lived for the skate off. It was so good. There are three contestants in this skate off, Skarn and then a guy in an all black suit with a white mask and then a guy in all blue. I will never get over Oscar in that blue suit.
我永远也忘不了。我对那些速度滑冰服非常好奇。所以我做了一次深入了解。关于速度滑冰服？是的。快讲讲。我在romper.com上看到了一篇关于速度滑冰服装演变的精彩文章。它最早始于1924年的奥运会，文章一直讲到了现
I will never get over it. I was very curious about the speed skating suits. So I did a mini dive. On speed skating suit? Yes. Do tell. I found a great article on romper.com about the evolution of speed skating outfits. It started really in the Olympics in 1924 and the article goes all the way to present
在。到了1972年，滑冰运动员开始穿着类似于我们现在看到的服装。它被称为紧身皮衣。它们是连体制服。它们超级紧身。它们包括手套和帽子或头罩，有助于使滑冰运动员更加符合空气动力学。它们甚至内置了防弹纤维补丁，用以保护关键身体部位。那听起来很重。
day. In 1972, skaters started wearing something along the lines of what we see now. It's known as a skin suit. They are one piece uniforms. They're ultra tight. They include gloves and a cap or a hood and they help make the skaters more aerodynamic. They even have Kevlar patches built in Kevlar to protect vital body parts. That seems heavy.
那不是挡子弹的东西吗？我是说，文章里就是这么说的。对于每个运动员来说，紧身皮衣都是通过获取身体各部位的整体测量数据来设计的。胸围、腰围、大腿围，全都要测量。它们是定制的吗？嗯，我猜在奥运会级别上是的。没错。
Isn't that the thing that stops bullets? I mean, that's what it said. For every player, the skin suit is designed by taking the overall measurements of body parts. Chest, waist, thigh, they're all measured. They're custom made? Well, I'm guessing at the Olympic level they are. Yeah, sure.
也许有那种你可以直接买到的小号、中号或大号的通用款。我不知道。头盔现在是短道速滑的强制装备，而且滑冰运动员可能会戴防弹纤维手套，以防被竞争对手的冰刀割伤。但是大道速滑运动员，也就是金面人和斯坎正在做的那种，他们不需要戴头盔或手套，但现在眼部防护是强制的。哇哦。而且詹娜，你问题的答案是：不，防弹纤维超级轻。
Maybe there's a generic one that you can just buy small, medium or large. I don't know. Helmets are now mandatory as part of a short track speed skating and also skaters may wear Kevlar gloves to prevent them from getting cut by their competitor skates. But long track skaters, which is kind of what Golden Face and Skarner are doing, they don't have to wear helmets or gloves, but now eye protection is mandatory. Wow. And Jenna, the answer to your question is no, Kevlar is super light.
这就是让它成为如此酷的产品的原因之一。但它能挡子弹吗？可以。它极其坚固，大概比钢坚固好几倍，而且超级超级轻。我只知道他们制作的一些非常棒的摩托车装备，你看上去不知道它不是普通的皮夹克，但能让你保持好好的和安全。哇。怎么样？
That's one of the things that makes it such a cool product. But does it stop bullets? It can. It's extremely, it's like a couple times stronger than steel and super, super light. I only know that they make some really great motorcycle stuff that you wouldn't know is not regular leather jacket, but keeps you nice and safe. Wow. How about that?
它还能在你滑冰时保护你的私密部位。那对我很重要。好吧，这场比赛的赢家将能进入全明星赛滑冰。是的。谁会想到呢？说到子弹和防弹，这场滑冰决斗也将变成一场枪战。但金面人并不是故意要伤害斯坎的，他只是想让他输。
It also protects your private parts when you're skating. Which are very important to me. Well the winner of this race is going to get to skate in the All-Star Game. Yeah. Who knew? And speaking of bullets and being bulletproof, this skate off is going to also turn into a shootout. But Golden Face didn't mean to hurt Skarn, he just wanted him to lose.
你妻子最近怎么样？我们应该稍微聊聊我们是如何拍摄这些滑冰场景的。冰场上的镜头是由马特·索恩拍摄的，他本人就是一个非常熟练的滑冰运动员。我是说，史蒂夫滑得很好。是的。但马特能够一边倒着滑冰一边拿着摄像机。哇。我知道。
And how's your wife? We should talk a little bit about how we filmed these skating scenes. The shots on the ice rink were shot by Matt Sohn, who was a very skilled skater himself. I mean, Steve is very good. Yes. But Matt was able to skate backwards while holding a camera. Wow. I know.
兰迪和马特聊过，他说我们的首席场务戴尔·亚历山大在冰鞋刀片上搭建了一个微型小摇臂，以帮助将摄像机降到冰面高度。哇。我们的摄像机也能滑冰了。这是马特的精确原话。你可以提醒詹娜和安吉拉，这是我们在整部剧的拍摄过程中使用摇臂最多的一次。哇。
Randy spoke to Matt and he said our key grip, Dale Alexander, built a tiny dolly on ice skate blades to help get the camera down at ice level. Wow. Our camera got to skate too. Here is Matt's exact quote. You can remind Jenna and Angela that it was the most we used a dolly for the entire run of the whole show. Wow.
是的。那是非常专业的。那是一种相当高级的技术拍摄。这让我想起了我和BJ的一次对话。你知道的，我去了他的餐馆，那个他经营的快闪店，叫Chain。是的。因为他们当时在和奇利斯餐厅合作。去Chain吃顿饭。
Yeah. That is very technical. That is a kind of advanced technical shoot. And this is reminding me of a conversation that I had with BJ. You know, I went to his restaurant, pop-up, that he does, Chain. Yes. Because they were doing a collaboration with Chili's. Eat a chain.
是的。我那天晚上在这个Chain里感受到了上帝。食物真的很好。我知道你是打包带走的。是的。我当时饿坏了，错过了晚饭，晚上10点左右把它们全吃光了。太惊艳了。他们甚至还给我做了一份无麸质版本的。
Yes. I got to feel God in this chain tonight. The food was really good. I know you got it as takeout. I did. I was so hungry and I had missed dinner and I ate all of it at like 10 o'clock at night. They were amazing. They even made me a gluten-free version.
主厨太棒了。好的。不管怎样，当我们在那儿的时候，我和BJ闲聊起《最高危机》，他说关于迈克尔的电影是应该拍得好还是拍得不好，曾有过一场巨大的辩论。他告诉我，当时担任运作人的保罗·利伯斯坦非常坚持认为，它看起来应该比你预期的要好，而不是比你预期的要差。而原因很简单，保罗说，这样看起会更有趣。
The chef's amazing. Okay. Anyway, while we were there, I was chatting with BJ about threat level midnight and he said that there was a huge debate about whether or not Michael's movie should be shot well or not well. And he's told me that Paul Lieberstein, who was the showrunner at the time, was very adamant that it should look better than you expect, not worse than you expect. And the reason for that was Paul just said, it'll be more fun to watch.
我们不需要让笑话变成像迈克尔砍掉了某人的脑袋那样。或者像摄像机在晃动那样。完全正确。BJ告诉我，他为之辩解的方式是，他喜欢想象这些年来迈克尔和几个纪录片摄制组成员成为了朋友。然后他把他们拉进来在空闲时间拍这个，但他们不能使用任何他们惊人的设备。他们只能用迈克尔的家用摄像设备。
We don't need the joke to be like that Michael cut off someone's head. Or like the camera's like shaky. Exactly. And BJ told me that the way he justified that was that he liked to imagine that over the years Michael had become friends with a couple of the documentary guys. And that he roped them into shooting this in their free time, but they couldn't use any of their amazing equipment. They just use Michael's home video equipment.
但由于他们的专业知识，他们可以想出一些你在家里拍时会用的方法，比如你不用摇臂，而是把它放在购物车上推着拍，或者把它放在滑板上什么的。但他们有这些绝招，这就是为什么《最高危机》能拍得这么好。这就提出了一个问题，那么这个纪录片摄制组已经存在11年了吗？我想是的。他们没有别的工作。他们是斯克兰顿人吗？
But because of their expertise, they could come up with these ways where like you would do it at home, like you would, instead of having a dolly, you would put it on a shopping cart and roll it or put it on a skateboard or something. But they had these tricks and that's why threat level midnight is shot so well. It does beg the question then, has this documentary crew been around for 11 years? I guess so. They have had no other job. Are they from Scranton?
但由于他们的专业知识，他们能想出这些在家就能办到的方法，比如，不用运货小车，而是把它放在购物车上推着，或者放在滑板上之类的。但他们掌握了这些诀窍，这就是为什么《威胁午夜》拍得这么好。这就引发了一个问题，这个纪录片摄制组已经存在11年了吗？我想是的。他们没有别的工作。他们是斯克兰顿人吗？
Yeah. What's I need to say? Locate to Scranton? These are good questions. Well, on the DVD commentary, BJ said that Matt Sohn did a really cool thing after everything was shot. He went back in and washed out the color of the footage of the movie to make it look even more distinctly different from the documentary footage.
对啊。我要说的是什么来着？定位到斯克兰顿？这些都是好问题。嗯，在DVD的评论音轨中，B·J说马特·索恩在所有镜头拍完后做了一件非常酷的事。他回去把电影素材的颜色冲洗淡了，好让它看起来和纪录片素材有更明显的区别。
And I could see it. I thought that was really smart because then you knew when you were watching the episode versus when you were watching threat level midnight. Yeah. But one more thing from the scene that I thought was really fun, you know, Golden Face has a golden gun. Yeah. BJ said Phil Shea just took it upon himself to make a golden gun.
我看得出来。我觉得这真的很聪明，因为这样你就能分清什么时候是在看剧集，什么时候是在看《头号危机》。对啊。不过这个场景还有一个我觉得非常搞笑的细节，你知道，黄金脸有一把金枪。对。B·J说菲尔·谢伊只是自告奋勇做了一把金枪。
It was not scripted that way. Oh, it was perfect. I know. And BJ was so tickled when he got to the ice rink and he saw the gold gun for Golden Face. But this is just the example of how every department was so excited to be a part of this project. It's so true.
剧本里可不是这么写的。哦，太完美了。我知道。当B·J来到溜冰场看到为黄金脸准备的金枪时，他高兴极了。但这只是每个部门都为能参与这个项目而兴奋不已的一个例子。确实如此。
I was going to realize that he's got to take out the guy who won. Well, he was number two. So if number one is gone, he'll get the slot. That's right. So he strangles Oscar's character with an American flag. He apologizes. This scene is much longer in the DVD version. So much longer.
我当时要意识到他必须干掉那个赢了的人。好吧，他是第二名。所以如果第一名没了，他就能补上这个空缺。没错。于是他用一面美国国旗勒死了奥斯卡的角色的脖子。他道了歉。DVD版本里的这个场景要长得多。长得多。
Oscar really makes a meal out of like his legs kicking and like all of it. It's pretty hilarious. One of my favorite details is that after Oscar has died, he continues to blink. Yeah. Did you notice? Oh, I noticed. This death scene is making everyone in the conference room a little uncomfortable. They're like, wow, that was dark.
奥斯卡把那种双腿乱踢的死状演得活灵活现，全过程都是如此。真是爆笑。我最喜欢的细节之一就是奥斯卡死后还在不停地眨眼。对。你注意到了吗？哦，我注意到了。这个死亡场景让会议室里的所有人都感到有点不自在。他们觉得，哇，这也太黑暗了吧。
Yeah. Well, you have to believe that they watched the extended cut. Yes. Back at Skarn Manor, Samuel is going to reveal some information. He has intercepted a name, Jasmine Winsong, but he doesn't know who the funky cat is. And Skarn says, not who, what? Because the funky cat is the hippest jazz club in town. Well, lady, before we go to the funky cat, I think we should take a little break.
对。好吧，你得相信他们看的是加长版。没错。回到斯坎庄园，塞缪尔要透露一些信息。他截获了一个名字，贾丝明·温松，但他不知道那个时髦猫是谁。斯坎说，不是谁，是什么？因为时髦猫是镇上最时髦的爵士俱乐部。好吧，女士，在我们去时髦猫之前，我想我们应该休息一下。
Because you're going to put your boob back in your bra? I actually am going to go and see if maybe I do some adjustments if I can make some more room on the left side. I'll let you know. When we come back, Jenna's boob will be in place and we're going to meet Jasmine Winsong. We're back. Here's what I've discovered. My boob is in, but it doesn't feel in because there's cup and then there's a little lace.
因为你要把胸部塞回文胸里吗？我其实正要去看看能不能做点调整，如果能让左边多出一点空间的话。我随时向你汇报。等我们回来，詹娜的胸部就会归位，然后我们要去见贾丝明·温松。我们回来了。这是我的发现。我的胸部进去了，但感觉没进去，因为有罩杯，然后还有一点蕾丝。
And I'm feeling it kind of bulge on the lace. So it's in. It's going to be fine, but it doesn't want to be there. I was trying to level up Angela. I was trying to maybe give the undergarments a geuge. Yes. And so I went with a bra with some lace on it. And I don't think the lace is for me.
我能感觉到它在蕾丝上有点凸出来。所以它是进去了。会没事的，但它就是不想呆在那儿。我当时是想让安吉拉的造型升级一下。我可能想给内衣加点花样。是的。所以我选了一款带蕾丝的文胸。我觉得蕾丝不适合我。
I just, you know, I'm almost 50 and I think I know what I like. I disagree. I think you can wear a lace in your 50s. I'm not saying you can't wear lace in your 50s. I'm saying my left boob is not a lace fan. I think your left boob is a lace fan. I just think the lace is a little wimpy and you might need some stronger lace. Oh, you need, you need big boob lace.
我只是觉得，你知道，我快50岁了，我想我知道自己喜欢什么。我不同意。我觉得你50岁也可以穿蕾丝。我不是说你50岁不能穿蕾丝。我是说我的左胸不是蕾丝的粉丝。我觉得你的左胸是蕾丝的粉丝。我只是觉得这蕾丝有点软弱无力，你可能需要更结实的蕾丝。哦，你需要，你需要大胸蕾丝。
Oh, maybe right now you have medium boob lace. I don't know. Well, you know who's probably wearing some lace. Jasmine Winsong. How do you like that for a transition? I think you did that great. She's up on the piano. She's singing as Michael enters the funky cat.
哦，也许你现在穿的是中号胸蕾丝。我不知道。好吧，你知道谁可能穿着蕾丝吗？贾丝明·温松。你觉得这个过渡怎么样？我觉得你做得太棒了。她站在钢琴上。当迈克尔走进时髦猫时，她在唱歌。
And Michael Skarn sits down at the piano. We cut to this amazing Jan talking head that I just simply could not love more. It was so perfect. I had to go to the shooting draft because I had to know if the bitch she was doing where she couldn't open the car door. Yes. Yes. I had to know if that was scripted.
迈克尔·斯坎在钢琴前坐下。镜头切到一个精彩绝伦的简的访谈画面，我简直不能再爱了。太完美了。我不得不去查拍摄剧本，因为我必须知道她开不了车门那个装腔作势的桥段。对。是的。我得知道那是不是剧本里写的。
Was it scripted? No. It's so great. It's not in the script. This is all it says of the shooting draft, Jan talking head. She's on the street walking to her car. Jan says, he finished his movie? No kidding.
是剧本里写的吗？没有。太棒了。剧本里根本没有。拍摄剧本里关于简的访谈只有这些。她在街上走向她的汽车。简说，他拍完了他的电影？不是吧。
Wow. That's great. Good for him. And I heard he has a serious girlfriend. That's so great. I'm great too. Okay. Well, sadly they cut out the end because I would have loved that snark from Jan.
哇。那太好了。真替他高兴。听说他还有个很认真的女朋友。太棒了。我也挺好的。好吧，可口的是他们把结尾剪掉了，因为我本来很想看看简那种尖酸刻薄的语气。
I love the choice that she's carrying a bag of dry cleaning to her car. I love that she can't get the door open. I love that they've clearly ambushed her on the street to ask her about her role in Threat Level Midnight. I love it all. I love her performance. And by the way, Jasmine Winsong is a very important part of this movie because she is going to sing backwards a very important clue.
我特别喜欢她提着一袋干洗衣服走向汽车的这个设定。我喜欢她打不开车门。我喜欢他们明显是在街上埋伏她，好问她关于《头号危机》里角色的事。我全都很喜欢。我喜欢她的表演。顺便说一句，贾丝明·温松这部电影中非常重要的一个角色，因为她将倒着唱出一个非常重要的线索。
Yes. Michael is going to record it with a special mini tape recorder that has like a little label maker that says backwards. Because if you put a label that says backwards, it just plays things backwards for you. The message says the hostages are under the stadium. But as soon as she delivers that message, she gets a dart to the neck. By assassin, Troy. Yes.
是的。迈克尔用一个特制的迷你录音机把它录下来，上面还贴了个写着“倒放”的小标签。因为如果你贴上一个写着“倒放”的标签，它就会为你倒着播放内容。信息说人质在体育场下面。但她刚传达完这个信息，脖子就中了一支飞镖。凶手是特洛伊。是的。
Troy Underbridge is back. And you know, his role is even larger in the extended version. Yeah. Location alert. The Funky Cat Jazz Club was filmed at Stove Piper Lounge in Northridge, California. And the lyrics for the song, they call me Jasmine Winsong, were written by BJ Novak. And the music was written by Eve Nelson. She was our amazing go-to composer on our show.
特洛伊·安德布里奇又回来了。你知道的，他在加长版里的戏份更多。是的。“外景警报”。时髦猫爵士俱乐部是在加利福尼亚州诺思里奇的斯托夫派珀酒廊拍摄的。那首歌《他们叫我贾丝明·温松》的歌词是B·J·诺瓦克写的。音乐是伊芙·纳尔逊写的。她是我们节目中出色的御用作曲家。
Back at the stadium, our hostage, Sandra, played by Pam, is going to beg Golden Face to let them all go. But it doesn't work. No. In fact, he decides to take out a hostage. Toby. Yeah, he needs to show how serious he is. We had a fan question from Anna T. in Peoria, Illinois.
回到体育场，由帕姆饰演我们的人质桑德拉，正苦求黄金脸放他们所有人走。但没用。不。事实上，他决定干掉一个人质。托比。是的，他需要展示自己有多狠。我们收到了来自伊利诺伊州皮奥里亚的安娜·T.的粉丝提问。
In this episode, Michael says that the scene with Toby's head explosion was the most expensive among all the scenes in the movie. And I'm wondering, which scene was the most expensive that you shot in the whole series of The Office, and which one was the most expensive for this episode? Well, as far as being the most expensive in the whole series. I have a guess. Yes? I know they had to build a whole entire gas station in a freeway.
在这集里，迈克尔说托比脑袋爆炸的那场戏是电影所有场景中最贵的一场。我想知道，在整部《办公室》系列中，你们拍过最贵的是哪一场？而这一集里最贵的又是哪一场？好吧，就整部系列中最贵的一场而言。我有个猜测。是吗？我知道他们必须在高速公路上搭建整个加油站。
Yes! Right, Angela! The gym-pam proposal scene. He said the second most expensive would probably go to filming on the boat in Niagara Falls, especially if you include all the travel and location expenses to get there. And Anna, as far as the most expensive scene in the episode, on the commentary, BJ said definitely he thought it was the Toby explosion, but Randy said, that's not accurate. Oh, really?
没错！对的，安吉拉！吉姆和帕姆的求婚场景。他说第二贵的可能是在尼亚加拉瀑布的船上拍摄，尤其是如果你把去那里的所有差旅和外景费用都算上的话。安娜，至于这一集里最贵的场景，在评论音轨中，B·J说他绝对认为那是托比爆炸的场景，但兰迪说，那不对。哦，真的吗？
Really? Randy thinks the sequence of scenes at the Funky Cat bar were more expensive because it included all of these elements, the music, the choreography, the extras, the costumes, the set dressing, all the signage, the locations, and the guest stars. Oh yeah, that makes sense. So Funky Cat wins most expensive scene. We got another fan question from Hannah B. in Wisconsin. I would love to know how you did make Toby's head explode.
真的吗？兰迪认为时髦猫酒吧的连续场景更贵，因为它包含了所有这些元素：音乐、编舞、群演、服装、布景、所有的标牌、外景和客串明星。哦，是的，这倒说得通。所以时髦猫赢得了最贵场景奖。我们收到了来自威斯康星州汉娜·B.的另一个粉丝提问。我很想知道你们是怎么做出托比脑袋爆炸的效果的。
How many times were you able to get this shot and did you have a safety meeting? Well, Hannah, BJ said they made two Toby heads, and in order to make the heads, Paul had to sit in a full-face plaster mold for hours, hours of time, that BJ said he could have been producing our show, but instead he was just sitting in a face mold. After that was done to get this shot, they rigged each of the molds with mild explosives. They filled one of them with blood, and then they set up cameras from three different angles and they filmed them exploding in slow motion. When they went back to review the footage, they said the one that was filled with blood
这个镜头你们拍了几次？你们开过安全会议吗？好吧，汉娜，B·J说他们做了两个托比的头，为了制作这些头，保罗不得不坐在全脸石膏模具里好几个小时，几个小时的时间，B·J说他本可以用来制作我们的节目，但他却只是坐在脸部模具里。做完这些后，为了拍这个镜头，他们在每个模具里都安装了温和的炸药。其中一个装满了血浆，然后他们从三个不同的角度架起摄像机，慢动作拍摄它们爆炸。当他们回看素材时，他们说那个装满血浆的
was just too disturbing. Oh, I bet. It was just too gruesome. It needed to look super fakey. It did. So that's why they ended up using the one that they did. I do remember Paul talking about sitting in all that plaster though, and he said it was a miserable experience.
实在是太令人不安了。哦，我敢打赌。实在是太血腥了。它需要看起来超级假才行。确实如此。所以这就是为什么他们最终用了现在这个。不过我还记得保罗说过坐在那一堆石膏里的事，他说那是一次痛苦的经历。
I mean, claustrophobic, like for hours, like don't you have a little kind of straw you breathe through? Yeah. Randy confirmed that, yes, we definitely had a safety meeting. We had to discuss protecting the camera crew from the shards of Toby's plaster, flies, yes, everywhere. But we removed the cast from the shot, which you can tell, which is very funny. No one is sitting around the dummy Toby.
我是说，幽闭恐惧症，持续好几个小时，难道你没有一根用来呼吸的小吸管吗？是的。兰迪证实了这一点，是的，我们绝对开过安全会议。我们必须讨论如何保护摄像团队免受托比的石膏碎片、苍蝇——是的，到处都是——的伤害。但我们把演员从镜头里移开了，你看得出来，这非常搞笑。没有人坐在假人托比周围。
And the whole thing cost about $5,700 in special effects and labor. Skarna and Samuel are going to arrive to save the hostages. It's very exciting. I know. And for some reason, Golden Face is going to reveal where the bomb is hidden. It's in the puck. Yeah. He tosses it to Skarn, and Skarn holds it and starts to reminisce about his life with
整个特效和人工成本大约是5700美元。斯坎和塞缪尔赶来营救人质了。太令人兴奋了。我知道。而且不知为何，黄金脸要透露炸弹藏在哪里。在冰球里。是的。他把它扔给斯坎，斯坎拿着它，开始缅怀他和
his wife. It's like a little montage playing on the hockey puck. This was our director, Tucker Gates' idea. And in the flashback montage, here's what Skarn sees. He sees himself painting his wife's toenails, and he's kind of blowing on them to dry them. He's also walking maybe animal cookie crackers or some kind of cracker across a woman's belly while they're laying on the grass, and then a ketchup fight. This montage makes so obvious how Michael has never really been in a healthy relationship.
他妻子的生活。就像曲棍球冰球上播放的一小段蒙太奇。这是我们的导演特克·盖茨的主意。在闪回蒙太奇中，斯坎看到了这些：他看到自己在给妻子的脚趾甲涂指甲油，他还一边吹气一边想把它们吹干。他们躺在草地上时，他还把动物饼干或某种饼干放在一个女人的肚皮上走来走去，然后是一场番茄酱大战。这段蒙太奇清楚地表明了迈克尔从来没有真正经历过一段健康的恋爱关系。
Because when he had to create a flashback love montage, these were the ideas he had of a blissful relationship. But I mean, Angela, ketchup fight, we've all done that, right? Oh, yeah. That's totally a normal part of courtship. And I personally love when Lee and I are in bed, and he moves the animal cracker across my belly. Well, I'm like, it's hot.
因为当他必须创作一段闪回恋爱蒙太奇时，这就是他脑海中幸福恋爱的样子。不过我的意思是，安吉拉，番茄酱大战，我们都做过，对吧？哦，是的。那是求爱过程中完全正常的一部分。我个人特别喜欢我和李在床上时，他把动物饼干在我肚皮上走来走去。好吧，我会觉得，这很火辣。
I'm like, hey, what, you want to paint my toenails? I mean, only if you blow on them after. Well Skarn is going to hurl the puck right back at Golden Face, and he's going to yell, go puck yourself. Charlie Grandi shared that he wrote, go puck yourself. Nice. This whole thing is going to end terribly. Golden Face is going to try to shoot Michael Skarn, and Samuel is going to jump in and
我会说，嘿，怎么，你想给我涂脚趾甲吗？我是说，除非你事后吹一吹。好吧，斯坎要把冰球狠狠地砸向黄金脸，他要大喊，去你个冰球。查理·格兰迪分享说那是他写的“去你个冰球”。太棒了。整件事将以惨剧收场。黄金脸要开枪打迈克尔·斯坎，而塞缪尔要跳出来
take that bullet. And then Golden Face is going to shoot Michael Skarn right after. Apparently, Samuel diving in front of the bullet was not scripted. It was not scripted. That was just Dwight. That one bullet pierced Michael Skarn's brain, lungs, heart, back, and balls. But it's going to take a lot more than that to take Skarn down. Good thing he's got a big, busty nurse to help make everything feel better.
挡下那一枪。然后黄金脸紧接着就要枪击迈克尔·斯坎。显然，塞缪尔飞身扑向子弹前并不是剧本里写的。那不是剧本写的。那是德怀特临场发挥。那一颗子弹击穿了迈克尔·斯坎的大脑、肺部、心脏、背部和蛋蛋。但要打倒斯坎可远不止需要这些。幸好他有一个身材丰满的大胸护士来帮他让一切感觉好点。
Oh, Helene. How awkward could you imagine? I mean, Pam is trying so hard to be supportive of this movie, and clearly, clearly, she never knew that her mom filmed a scene for Threat Level Midnight. I feel like she's discovering it in the moment. I can't believe her mom wouldn't tell her. I wore a super-cadooper push-up bra and leaned into a camera. Back at the White House, a fully recovered Skarn is going to tell the president that
哦，海伦。你能想象有多尴尬吗？我是说，帕姆拼命地想支持这部电影，很显然，很显然，她从来不知道她妈妈为《头号危机》拍过一场戏。我觉得她是在当场发现这一点的。我真不敢相信她妈妈不告诉她。我穿了一个超无敌聚拢文胸，还把身子倾向镜头。回到白宫，完全康复的斯坎要告诉总统
the bomb is in the puck. Plot twist coming. Yeah. Golden Face and his sidekick are going to walk into the president's office with cahoots, machine guns. Yeah. The president is in on it. Skarn is going to smash a picture of Abraham Lincoln over the president's head to escape.
炸弹在冰球里。剧情反转来了。是的。黄金脸和他的走狗带着机关枪闯进了总统办公室。是的。总统也是同伙。斯坎把一幅亚伯拉罕·林肯的画像砸在总统头上以求逃跑。
Carrie Kemper pitched the joke of Michael smashing the painting over the president's head. Well, Randy said that that picture was a public domain image. It was free to use, and our art department printed multiple copies of it on easy-to-tear paper. I love the choice that Craig made as the president in this movie to sort of stick his head out in anticipation of getting the Abraham Lincoln portrait on his head. Yeah.
凯瑞·肯珀提出了迈克尔把画砸在总统头上的这个笑话。好吧，兰迪说那张照片是公共版权图片。可以免费使用，我们的美术部门用易撕纸打印了多份。我非常喜欢克雷格在这部电影里饰演总统时的选择，他把头探出去，似乎在预料着亚伯拉罕·林肯的肖像要砸在自己头上。是的。
It's so good. It's so good. I also love whenever Andy's character Billy the bartender is in a scene, when it cuts to Andy, he's melding the words. Yes, in the conference room. So we had a fan question from Tom M. in Grand Rapids, Michigan, who said, I imagine this was a tricky episode to film since you have to act in this movie how your character would act and none of the characters are professional actors, except for maybe Andy.
太棒了。太棒了。我也很喜欢每当安迪饰演的酒保比利出现在场景中时，镜头一切到安迪，他都在对口型。是的，在会议室里。所以我们收到了来自密歇根州大急流城的汤姆·M.的粉丝提问，他说，我猜这一集拍起来很棘手，因为你必须在这部电影中表现得像你的角色会演的那样，而且没有一个角色是专业演员，除了安迪可能算一个。
How hard was it as an actor to act poorly where there takes where maybe your acting was too good? Tom, this is really interesting because we did all put a lot of thought into what kind of performers were each of our characters. And again, kind of like what BJ said about how Paul didn't want the camera work to be terrible. We were also directed to not be awful actors, maybe a little stiff, maybe camera aware. Yes.
作为一个演员，要演得糟糕有多难？有没有哪个镜头可能你演得太好了？汤姆，这真的很有趣，因为我们确实都花了很多心思去琢磨我们的每一个角色到底是哪种表演者。而且，就像B·J之前说的，保罗不想让摄像机运镜变得很烂一样。我们也被指导不要演得很烂，也许可以有点生硬，也许有点镜头意识。是的。
Yes. But you've seen those videos that people post maybe where they're acting out a skit at their job. I watched some of those on YouTube because I was like, I think that would be Pam. Like Pam would just say all of her lines very simply with earnestness almost as if she was reading them. Yeah. Without any pauses.
是的。但你见过那些人们发布的视频吧，也许他们在工作中表演一个小品。我在YouTube上看了其中一些，因为我想，那应该就是帕姆的样子。就像帕姆会用极其简单、真诚的态度说出她所有的台词，几乎就像她在朗读一样。是的。没有任何停顿。
Yes. Exactly. Without any inflections. Well, we're not at this part yet, but I can tell you when I had to learn the dance, I had to take the hip sass down a notch. Oh, because of your natural hip sass? I liked it. You know, sachet and I had to tone that down.
是的。没错。没有任何语调起伏。好吧，我们还没到这一部分，但我可以告诉你，当我不得不学这段舞蹈时，我必须把臀部的扭动收敛一点。哦，因为你天生就爱扭臀？我挺喜欢的。你知道，恰恰舞步，我不得不收敛一下。
We are finally going to make it to the bar and we see Billy played by Andy. Oh, Andy was so excited to make this character happen. Billy's TV doesn't work. How's that for problems? And I loved it when Michael was like, don't ever change Billy. At 12 minutes 52 seconds, when the group of Bachelorettes give Michael a drink, did anyone else think it looked like my husband's? The F train to Brooklyn extra bidders?
我们终于要到酒吧了，我们看到了由安迪饰演的比利。哦，安迪为了让这个角色登场兴奋极了。比利电视坏了。这算什么麻烦事？我特别喜欢迈克尔说的那句，永远别变，比利。在12分52秒时，当那一群单身派对女郎给迈克尔一杯饮料时，有没有人觉得看起来像我丈夫的那个？布鲁克林F线列车的临时演员？
Yes, I did, Angela. Yeah. With the little toothpick. The whole thing. We talked about this with BJ. All of the Bachelorettes actually had a line. It's in the extended cut on the DVD if you want to see the full scene. Yes.
是的，我看到了，安吉拉。是的。带着一根小牙签。全套的。我们跟B·J聊过这个。所有的单身派对女郎其实都有一句台词。如果你想看完整版场景，DVD的加长版里有。是的。
I've got a location alert. This location was the same as the Funky Cat. We just used a different side of the bar. Oh, yeah. So smart. Mm-hmm. Well, Karen is going to have a talking head saying, why did you single my line out? Like a million years later.
我有一个外景警报。这个外景地和时髦猫是一样的。我们只是用了酒吧的另一边。哦，对。太聪明了。嗯哼。好吧，凯伦会有一个访谈画面说，为什么你要把我的台词单独拎出来？就像过了好几百万年一样。
And at 13 minutes, four seconds for my background folks, you will see another cameo callback. Dan Gore is exiting the cafe behind Karen's talking head. You know, Dan played Karen's baby daddy. Yes. Didn't he dress as a hot dog in a photo on her desk or something like that? That's amazing. As the scene continues in the bar, we find out that Skarn is really depressed, you know, and Billy is going to cheer him up.
在13分04秒，对于我的背景演员朋友们，你们会看到另一个客串彩蛋。丹·戈尔在凯伦的访谈画面后面走出了咖啡馆。你知道的，丹演的是凯伦孩子的爹。是的。他不是在她的桌子照片里打扮成热狗什么的吗？太棒了。随着场景在酒吧继续，我们发现斯坎真的很沮丧，你知道的，而比利要让他高兴起来。
He tells a random kid in overalls, who is this kid? That kid was played by Joshua Reed. All I could think of is like, is this a shrewt? Like, is one of Dwight's nephews or cousins in town? Anyway, he tells the little boy to hit G9 on the jukebox. It's time to dance the Skarn. Oh, we talked about this with BJ. It was so fun.
他对一个穿工装裤的随机小孩说——这小孩是谁呀？那小孩是约书亚·里德演的。我满脑子都在想，这是施鲁特吗？难道德怀特的侄子或表亲进城了？不管怎样，他叫小男孩按点唱机上的G9。是时候跳斯坎舞了。哦，我们跟B·J聊过这个。太有趣了。
All you guys are so funny. I love all the cameos in the background of this scene. We've got the whole warehouse. And then we have Leo from Vance Refrigeration, but not Gino. I guess in real life, Gino was like, nah, I don't want to do the Skarn. Well, Leo's having a good time. And we also have Todd Packer. Yeah.
你们所有人都太逗了。我喜欢这个场景背景中的所有客串。我们有整个仓库的人。然后我们有万斯制冷公司的里奥，但不是吉诺。我猜现实生活中吉诺大概是说，不，我不想跳斯坎舞。好吧，里奥玩得很开心。我们还有托德·帕克。是的。
I will tell you, the day we filmed this was such a blast. We of course had to learn the dance and practice it a few times. And we also had to figure out how our character would dance, how up for it they would dance. It would be. And I just have such fond memories of this day. We had a fan question from Avery G and Idaho who asked, who choreographed the Skarn? Well, I'll tell you, first of all, the lyrics were by BJ and the music was by Eve Nelson again.
我告诉你们，我们拍这一天的时候简直嗨翻了。我们当然必须学习舞蹈并排练好几次。我们还得弄清楚我们的角色会怎么跳，他们会有多大热情去跳。这会是怎样的。关于这一天，我有太美好的回忆了。我们收到了来自爱达荷州艾弗里·G.的粉丝提问，他问，谁是斯坎舞的编舞？好吧，我来告诉你，首先，歌词是B·J写的，音乐依然是伊芙·纳尔逊写的。
And the choreography was by Mary Ann Kellogg. She's done all our choreography on the show and she's great. Well, she was very patient with us. If you look at the group who learned the Skarn, we are all different levels of dance skill set. I mean, this is not a difficult dance, though. It's not. But we had to get the timing right, but we also had to make it look like we didn't over
而编舞是玛丽安·凯洛格。她给我们节目的所有舞蹈编过舞，她太棒了。好吧，她对我们非常有耐心。如果你看看学斯坎舞的那群人，我们的舞蹈功底各不相同。我是说，这其实不是一支难跳的舞蹈。不难。但我们必须把节奏踩对，同时还得让我们看起来好像并没有
know it. Do you know what I mean? I do. Back in the conference room, the Skarn is giving Jim the giggles. He can't stop laughing. Here's a tidbit for you. On the DVD, they said, we shot this conference room scene with everyone reacting on the first day.
太熟练。你知道我的意思吗？我懂。回到会议室里，斯坎让吉姆笑个不停。他笑得停不下来。这里有个小花絮告诉你。在DVD里，他们说，我们在第一天就拍了这个会议室里所有人的反应场景。
So nothing had been filmed yet. So John is laughing at nothing. Wait. So the entire time we cut back to the conference room, all of us are watching nothing? Nothing. Can you believe that? I mean, I don't even remember it that way. That's what's so crazy.
所以当时什么都还没拍呢。所以约翰对着空气在笑。等等。所以我们在镜头切回会议室的整个过程中，我们所有人都在看着空气？空气。你敢相信吗？我是说，我的记忆里甚至都不是这样的。这才是最疯狂的地方。
I was there. BJ said, John, when he's having this laughing fit, is watching nothing and he was amazed at hell well it timed out. Wow. Well, the laughing is going to really upset Michael and so much so he's going to pause the movie and walk out. Yep. I was like, no, no, no.
我就在那里。B·J说，约翰这小子在大笑爆发的时候，他看着空气，而且他对节奏的把控精准得让他自己都惊呆了。哇。好吧，这个笑声会让迈克尔很不高兴，以至于他要暂停电影走出去。对。我当时想，不，不，不。
The movie's great. Don't leave. And that's when Michael turns to Holly and says if she liked the movie and she says, which part? Oh, no. Yeah. This leads to that scene in the annex that we talked all about with BJ and Michael's talking head about ants versus a bug's life.
这电影挺好的。别走。就在这时，迈克尔转身问霍莉她是否喜欢这部电影，她说，哪一部分？哦，不。是的。这就引出了我们在附属办公室跟B·J聊过的那个场景，以及迈克尔关于蚂蚁和《虫虫危机》的访谈。
Yeah. And Michael, who is heartbroken that Holly does not understand how important this movie is to him, is going to watch the rest of the movie without her. Yeah. But as he watches it without her, he starts to sort of see it through her filter, right? Yeah. And as he's looking at her empty seat, he then looks out the conference room window and there she is.
是的。迈克尔因为霍莉不理解这部电影对他有多重要而心碎，他决定不等她，自己看剩下的电影。是的。但当他独自观看时，他开始透过她的视角来看待这部电影，对吧？是的。当他看着她空着座位时，他随后望向会议室的窗户，她就在那儿。
She's watching it. He runs out to her. He apologizes. She apologizes. They kiss. They go back in to watch it together. They're such a good couple. They really are.
她在看。他跑向她。他道歉。她道歉。他们接吻。他们一起走回去接着看。他们真是绝配。他们真的是。
She gets him and she's making him a better person. Yes. I think that was the whole point of this plot, was to mature Michael. Mm-hmm. Lady, we had a fan question from Paige M. in Philly. Paige asks, when everyone is watching Threat Level Midnight for the second time, Michael gets up to check on Holly. At that time, Golden Face is telling Pam why his face is gold.
她懂他，而且她正在让他变成一个更好的人。是的。我觉得这个情节的核心意义，就是让迈克尔走向成熟。嗯哼。伙计，我们收到了来自费城佩吉·M.的粉丝提问。佩吉问，当大家第二次观看《头号危机》时，迈克尔起身去查看霍莉的情况。当时，黄金脸正在告诉帕姆为什么他的脸是金色的。
However, the audience misses it because we are listening to Michael and Holly's conversation. I want to know, what was he saying? I actually found this scene in the shooting draft, but it's also in the extended movie on the DVD as well. I'm going to set it up from the shooting draft and then I'm going to play the clip. Great. The script said, Interior Stadium warehouse. The hostages are scared.
然而观众错过了，因为我们在听迈克尔和霍莉的对话。我想知道，他当时在说什么？我其实在拍摄剧本里找到了这个场景，但它也在DVD的加长版电影里。我先从拍摄剧本里把它还原出来，然后我再播放这个片段。太棒了。剧本写道，内景，体育场仓库。人质们很害怕。
Kevin is praying. Roy says to Pam, now's your chance. Go talk to Golden Face. See what you can do. Pam approaches Golden Face. And in the script, it says that Pam's character is flirtatious. Oh. Hmm.
凯文在祈祷。罗伊对帕姆说，现在是你的机会。去跟黄金脸谈谈。看看你能做点什么。帕姆走近黄金脸。剧本里写着，帕姆的角色表现得很轻佻。哦。嗯。
Hmm. So Pam has some stage direction. Let's hear the rest of it. Now's your chance. Go talk to Golden Face. See what you can do. Okay. Hey, Golden Face.
嗯。所以帕姆有一些舞台调度。我们听听剩下的部分。现在是你的机会。去跟黄金脸谈谈。看看你能做点什么。好的。嘿，黄金脸。
Can I ask you a question? I mean, since we're all going to die here anyway, why is your face gold? Why do you care? I'm just making conversation. I worked in a gold factory. We had a boss who only cared about money. He wouldn't give us lunch break, so we had to eat the gold. And then one day, I looked in the mirror and, well, I guess you are what you eat.
我能问你个问题吗？我是说，反正我们都快死在这儿了，为什么你的脸是金色的？你管得着吗？我只是在闲聊。我在黄金工厂工作过。我们有个老板只关心钱。他不让我们吃午饭休息，所以我们不得不吃黄金。然后有一天，我照了照镜子，嗯，我想你吃什么像什么。
Golden Face, that is so sad. Well, I just thought if I could blow up all the All Star games, all the trophies would explode all over the place and then everyone would be gold, just like me. Please let us go, Golden Face. So sad. You know what you can't see when you play that clip is that at the end of that scene, Sandra, played by Pam, gives Golden Face a kiss on his cheek. Yeah.
黄金脸，这也太惨了吧。好吧，我只是觉得如果我能炸掉所有的全明星赛，所有的奖杯就会到处爆炸，然后每个人都会像我一样变成金色的。求求你放我们走吧，黄金脸。太惨了。你播放那个片段时看不到的是，在那个场景结束时，由帕姆饰演的桑德拉在黄金脸的脸颊上亲了一下。是的。
And in the shooting draft, it said, after the scene plays, you cut back to real time in the conference room and Jim and Pam are holding hands enjoying the scene, remembering what that meant to them. I mean, Pam got to kiss Jim's cheek in front of Roy. I know. Wow. Back in the movie, Michael Skarn has taken to the ice. I really love the detail that Michael tells us in the conference room, which is that he
在拍摄剧本里写着，这个场景演完后，镜头切回会议室里的现实时间，吉姆和帕姆手拉着手欣赏着这个场景，回忆着这对他们的意义。我是说，帕姆居然在罗伊面前亲了吉姆的脸颊。我知道。哇。回到电影中，迈克尔·斯坎已经踏上了冰面。我真的很喜欢迈克尔在会议室里告诉我们的那个细节，那就是他
filmed this during an actual Scranton High School hockey game and that it was kind of a big deal because they were trying to qualify and then the team got disqualified because Michael messed things up. He ruined all of their dreams of going on and winning a championship. They had had an undefeated season up until now. Yeah. Michael was disqualified because this idiot took to the ice to film his movie. Well, the actual location of this shoot was at the Valencia Ice Station and all of those
是在一场真正的斯克兰顿高中曲球比赛期间拍摄的，这算是一件大事，因为他们当时正试图获得资格，结果因为迈克尔把事情搞砸了，球队失去了资格。他毁了他们继续前进并赢得冠军的所有梦想。在此之前他们保持着不败赛季。是的。迈克尔被取消资格，因为这个白痴踏上冰面去拍他的电影。好吧，这次拍摄的实际地点在巴伦西亚冰上运动中心，所有这些
people were extras that we hired, of course. It was a big production. It really was. Cherokee Jack is going to visit Skarn from the dead. Are you a ghost? Yeah. Yeah. And he's going to tell Skarn to take out all of his frustrations on that hockey puck
人当然都是我们雇来的群演。这是一场大制作。确实是。切罗基·杰克从死里复活来探望斯坎。你是鬼吗？对。是的。他告诉斯坎要把所有的挫折都发泄在那个曲棍球冰球上
and Skarn hits it so hard that it flies into space. It hits a satellite. Yeah. All of a sudden, Billy's TV works again. And then it eventually lands in the lap of Golden Face, who's sitting in his backyard counting a suitcase full of money. Yeah. He's in a lawn chair counting money.
斯坎狠狠地一击，冰球直飞太空。它击中了卫星。是的。比利电视突然又好用了。然后它最终落在了坐在后院数一箱钱的黄金脸的怀里。是的。他坐在沙滩椅上数钱。
Where did the money come from? I don't know. But he goes, oh, shit. Oh. Standards and practices. Lip flap. Here were the notes from Standards and Practices. Scene 86, please lose the underlined or have the explosion start sooner when we see the
钱从哪来的？我不知道。但他喊道，哦，靠。哦。审查标准。口型破绽。以下是审查标准的意见。第86场，请去掉下划线，或者让爆炸从我们看到冰球落在黄金脸的膝盖上、他说“哦，靠”时更早开始。而且他们给“靠”字加了下划线。有人就觉得，听着，除非你加下划线，否则他们不会把我们当回事。
puck land on Golden Face's lap and he says, oh, shh. And they underlined the shh. Somebody was like, listen, they're not going to take us seriously unless you underline it. It's in bold. They put it in bold, too. Here's my other note. Make it bold, underline it.
加粗了。他们还加粗了。这是我的另一个意见。加粗，加下划线。
We have a highlighter, highlight it. Put an arrow by it. So that's why we can see John's mouth go into the shh. We were allowed that silent lip flap, but the explosion had to go off before we heard him make the sound. Underline it. Exactly. Well, the location of this scene was our very own Tom Melby's backyard.
我们有个荧光笔，高亮一下。在旁边画个箭头。所以这就是为什么我们可以看到约翰的嘴做出了“靠”的口型。我们被允许有那个无声的口型，但爆炸必须在我们听到他发出声音之前发生。加下划线。完全正确。好吧，这个场景的外景地是我们自己的汤姆·梅尔比的后院。
I recognized it immediately. Me, too, right away. He lived in a house right behind our stages. Yeah. We've talked about it. He had a little swing and I'd walk over there with Isabelle on my lunch. Well, everyone cheers. Skarn has saved the day.
我一眼就认出来了。我也是，马上就认出来了。他住的房子就在我们摄影棚后面。是的。我们聊过这个。他有个小秋千，我午休时会带着伊莎贝尔散步过去。好吧，大家欢呼雀跃。斯坎拯救了世界。
It's amazing. He's back at his house. He's having breakfast and the president calls again. He has another mission for Skarn. Should he choose to accept? Also one side note, yes, he realizes, oh yeah, he did make Dwight a robot. Yes, because there is a scene of him oiling his circuit board. And as the movie comes to an end, the narrator, it's been Stanley's voice this whole time.
太棒了。他回到了自己的房子里。他正在吃早餐，总统又打电话来了。他给斯坎安排了另一个任务。如果他愿意接受的话？还有个小花絮，对，他意识到，哦对了，他把德怀特做成了一个机器人。是的，因为有一个他给他的电路板上油的场景。随着电影接近尾声，旁白，从头到尾都是斯坦利的声音。
Plot twist. That voice is coming out of Michael Skarn. He is Michael Skarn. He's been narrating his own story the whole time. The office erupts in cheers. It's a huge hit. Everybody loved Threat Level Midnight. Yeah.
剧情反转。那个声音是从迈克尔·斯坎嘴里发出来的。他就是迈克尔·斯坎。他一直在讲述他自己的故事。办公室里爆发出一阵欢呼。大获成功。每个人都喜欢《头号危机》。是的。
It was a pretty fun day at the office. You know, the episode ends with the sort of end credits for the movie and the theme song of Threat Level Midnight that we talked about with BJ. I thought it was really cute on the DVD. This is how that song is credited. It says theme from Threat Level Midnight, music and lyrics by Michael Scott, performed by Andrew Bernard, inspired by the music of Will Smith. I just love when Michael always gives credit to who inspired him.
办公室里度过了相当有趣的一天。你知道的，这一集以电影的片尾演职员表和我们在B·J聊过的《头号危机》主题曲结束。我觉得DVD上的这个设计真的很可爱。这就是这首歌演职员表上的署名。上面写着《头号危机》主题曲，词曲由迈克尔·斯科特创作，安德鲁·伯纳德演唱，灵感来自威尔·史密斯的音乐。我就是喜欢迈克尔总是把功劳归于那些启发了他的人。
Well on the DVD, BJ and Charlie talked about this final wrap at the end and Charlie wrote it. And BJ said he remembered that Charlie wrote it in what seemed to be like five minutes. It just flowed. Yeah. Well, at the end of the credits, there was going to be an additional tag of Dwight as Samuel coming in and telling you to go home. Go home.
在DVD上，B·J和查理谈到了结尾处的这个收尾，是查理写的。B·J说他记得查理写这个好像只用了五分钟。一气呵成。好吧，在片尾演职员表的最后，本来还有一个额外的彩蛋，是作为塞缪尔的德怀特走进来叫你回家。回家。
It's over. Like at the end of Ferris Bueller. Yeah. But we didn't have time. It's really cute though. It's in the extended cut. Well that was our breakdown of Threat Level Midnight, but I do have one more little tidbit to share, Angela.
结束了。就像《春天不是读书天》的结尾一样。是的。但我们当时没时间。不过真的很可爱。加长版里有。好吧，这就是我们对《头号危机》的深度解析，不过我还有一个小花絮要分享，安吉拉。
Last year there was a band called The Network who appeared on The Tonight Show and they performed a song called Threat Level Midnight. Oh yeah? The Network is a new wave band, but they are a side project of the rock band Green Day. Oh, Billy Joe, our best friend. Your best friend. I'm kind of glomming on now. You hung out.
去年有一个名叫“网络”的乐队上了《今夜秀》，他们表演了一首名为《头号危机》的歌。哦，是吗？“网络”是一支新浪潮乐队，但他们是摇滚乐队绿日乐队的一个副业项目。哦，比利·乔，我们最好的朋友。你最好的朋友。我现在有点在硬套近乎了。你们一起玩过。
I met him. We hung out. We had a really nice conversation. The three of us are basically best friends now, Angela, in your mind. We have a photo to prove it. We'll put it in stories because I'm dying to prove our friendship. But anyway, it's a really fun song. And actually when they went to release this, Billy Joe texted me this song out of nowhere
我见到他了。我们一起玩过。我们聊得非常愉快。在你的脑海里，我们三个人基本上已经是最好的朋友了，安吉拉。我们有照片为证。我们会把它发到快拍里，因为我太想证明我们的友谊了。不管怎样，这是一首非常好听的歌。其实当他们发行这首歌时，比利·乔莫名其妙地把这首歌发短信给我
with no context. I didn't even know he had started watching The Office yet. It's really catchy and my family listens to it all the time. So I thought maybe we could end this episode by playing it. Let's hear it. Threat Level Midnight by The Network. Yes. Well, there you have it, guys.
没有任何前言。我甚至都不知道他已经开始看《办公室》了。这首歌真的很洗脑，我家人经常听。所以我想也许我们可以通过播放这首歌来结束这一集。我们来听听看。网络乐队的《头号危机》。好的。好吧，各位，你们都听到了。
That's Threat Level Midnight. A big thank you to BJ Novak for joining us today. Yes, and Randy Cordray for all the behind-the-scenes details, and you guys for sending in your questions and comments. Thanks so much. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
这就是《头号危机》。非常感谢B·J·诺瓦克今天加入我们。是的，还有兰迪·科德雷为我们提供所有幕后细节，也谢谢你们发来你们的问题和评论。非常感谢。我们下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制片。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用一个月Stitcher Premium，请使用优惠码OFFICE。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。